Here we go,
four,
three,
two,
one.
And we're live.
Gentlemen,
thanks for being here.
Appreciate it.
Let everybody know who you are.
Lane.
Uh,
I'm a meathead who likes science,
got no bodybuilding when I was young.
Uh,
and then did a bs in biochemistry,
phd in Nutritional Science.
Um,
kept lifting,
did powerlifting,
won two national championships,
got silver medal at worlds within worlds
squat record and it also bodybuilding
and one of the natural pro card.
They actually have natural bodybuilding,
believe it or not.
And uh,
throughout that time,
just know when I first got into it,
one magazine said one thing and even in
the same magazine they have an article
one month next month that would
contradicted.
So I was like,
I'm just going to try and figure this
shit out for myself.
So,
which is the place that a lot of people
listening are at right now.
Yeah.
And it's,
it's tough because it's kind of like,
who do you trust because,
nope,
not everybody has the time or the energy
to go and do a degree in this stuff.
So.
But that was me.
I kinda got down the rabbit hole of,
all right,
let's try and figure this nutrition
stuff out.
And of course the more I learn,
the more I realized I didn't know.
But uh,
yeah,
it just became a passion for me to enter
this day.
I'm still very,
I love this stuff.
This is what gets me up,
gets me going.
Well guys,
like you are very important guys who
actually trained very hard and really
understand the science this is because
it's usually one or the other.
Yeah,
absolutely.
Yeah.
And I like when I was doing,
I graduated my phd in 2010 when we
started.
We actually both knew each other from
the bodybuilding.com
message boards,
so that was back before social media
trained together back in 2006 or seven
seven and experimental biology.
So this big,
there's a big symposium every year for
science geeks and we were both going to
it and we found out about each other on
the forums and we went and trained
together and he's a,
he's a beast.
Uh,
and uh,
yeah,
we really hit it off and we've been
friends since then.
So for everybody who's looking for a
fight,
so sorry,
we're probably going to be pretty
friendly.
Well,
it's going to be a conversation.
We don't need to have a fight.
Dom,
you've been on the podcast before,
but for people didn't listen to that
one.
Please tell them who you are and what
you do.
Yeah.
Uh,
um,
keep this sucker google.
Yeah,
yeah,
sure.
Uh,
I will go.
Getting back,
I majored in nutrition actually as an
Undergrad but didn't actually see a
career in it that much.
So I went into neuroscience,
the net 90,
so it's a decade of the brain and uh,
my,
my formal training is in neuroscience
and it got steered towards basically
changing the neuropharmacology of the
brain with nutrition and that's what the
key to genic diet does and it has
tremendous benefits I think for military
personnel,
which is,
um,
funded by the office of navy research
and the Department of Defense to develop
ketogenic strategies to enhance
readiness,
a resilience and performance and safety
and military personnel.
And what,
what did,
why specifically does the key to genic
diet helped military people?
I know there's a thing with a navy seals
with preventing epilepsy.
Yeah,
so a central nervous system,
oxygen toxicity,
a limitation of that is a limitation of
navy seal diving is oxygen toxicity
seizures and a antiepileptic drugs are
not really a viable option because they
can,
their side effects,
they can decrease cognitive resilience,
physical resilience,
it key to jenks strategy is something
that's being studied now from a basic
science mechanistic perspective to
animal work to now human studies.
So it's not,
you know,
out in the field yet,
but some guys are actually doing it and
I studied the science of that.
And so when people don't understand what
we're saying,
um,
for some folks who have epilepsy,
the ketogenic diet has been shown to
stop seizures.
Absolutely.
Go Google the Charlie Foundation.
So that's how I actually got linkedin.
And actually I met a natural drug free
bodybuilder.
His name was Mike Dancer and he had
severe terminal epilepsy,
Google,
Mike Dancer,
Ketogenic Diet.
And you'll find an amazing story about a
guy who used nutrition to manage his
epilepsy when drugs failed and he used
it to prep and when bodybuilding shows
and compete in bodybuilding and the
rebreathers sometimes caused seizures
with some of the soldiers they can.
So,
uh,
for example,
just 50 feet of sea water using a closed
circuit rebreather,
like a drager,
rebreathers,
50 feet of seawater.
Your potential for getting oxygen
toxicity seizures can occur in just 10
minutes.
So that's a little bit of time and
that's not very deep.
So there's no way to predict that and
there's no way as of now to prevent
that.
So we study physiological biomarkers
that could warn people of an impending
seizure.
And we also develop countermeasures to
mitigate oxygen toxicity seizures.
I focus mostly on drugs.
I'm in a pharmacology and physiology
department,
but I realized that people with
epilepsy,
the ketogenic diet was more effective
than drugs.
So I got steered into,
you know,
nutrition,
which was my undergrad.
And then that kicked off about 10 years
ago and I've just been deep into
probably a dozen or more different
applications of nutritional ketosis.
Awesome.
And laying up and paying attention to
online for a long time.
One of the things you do a great job
with is just calling bullshit on.
I mean,
you loved call bullshit clearly,
but whenever people are overstating
claims or people get ridiculous,
and I think this is one of the things
that is a problem with any diet where
people get really enthusiastic about it.
That becomes an ideology.
Whether it's the key to genic died or
the carnivore diet or the,
you know,
fill in the blanks,
Vegan Diet.
People decide this is the end all be
all.
It's going to cure cancer.
Make you smarter,
Dick's going to grow a foot.
All these things are gonna happen.
And you do a great job of calling
bullshit on that kind of stuff.
Yeah,
I mean,
I,
I'm not anti Quito,
I'm not anti.
I'm anti
bullshit.
And one of the problems we have is
nutrition is replacing religion for a
lot of people.
So you find something that you identify
with and then people start to try to say
because they identify with that movement
or like for example,
vegans,
they identify with many of them.
Uh,
protection of animals,
not my job to judge their ethics on that
sort of thing,
but then they kind of tried to backtrack
to find the science to support them as
well and they,
they pick and choose.
And this is guilty of all groups,
not just vegans.
This is also a lot of key digital diet
cell.
It's a carnivore diet,
whatever have you.
If it has the word diet,
there's zealots out there who are going
after it and I will stick up for.
I've stuck up at a scientific conference
for the key to genic diet.
Uh,
you were,
we were having a round table about
something different and somebody said,
well,
we know that the ketogenic diet in
prayers exercise performance and
endurance athletes.
And I said,
I don't think that's necessarily true of
the,
it's pretty ambivalent or ambiguous as
to whether or not it does.
It seems to be kind of individual.
But on the whole,
on the average,
it doesn't seem to impair exercise
performance.
So it's kind of what you like.
But when you have people who,
you know,
like,
like a Gary Taubes,
who says,
well,
calories don't matter.
It's all carbohydrates,
that sort of thing of the carbohydrate,
insulin model of obesity.
I mean the research is you're able to do
a lot of hand waving about insulin and
when you burn so much fat,
when you're on a high fat diet,
which is true by the way you,
you burn a lot of fat,
but what they don't talk about is that
it's it's overall fat balance,
how much fat you store versus how much
fat you burn,
and when you're on a high fat diet,
you store a lot of fat,
you also burn a lot of fat.
The overall caloric balance is what
determines whether or not you will have
net storage or net deposition in St
Louis for high carb Diet as well.
You know this idea that with high
insulin it just completely shuts down
all fat burning everywhere that that's
just not true.
Now if you have high carbohydrate,
you will burn less fat,
but you're also storing less fat as
well,
and again,
the net caloric balance is going to be
what determines how much you store
because you don't really store
carbohydrates as fat.
For most people,
they did a study,
a overfeeding women where they overfed
them 50 percent above their caloric
maintenance and they found that of 282
grams of fat that they stored during the
day and adipose.
Only four grams came from carbohydrate.
Two hundred and 78 came from fat,
so glucose.
What about fructose?
Fructose causes we think you know,
nonalcoholic fatty liver disease,
so that could be,
you know,
Denovo Denovo lipogenesis is higher with
fructose and you're thinking about
people consuming it in a liquid,
drinks a 100 to 200 grams a day,
which is not uncommon even for my wife,
not uncommon,
so fructose does seem to have a little
bit of different hepatic metabolism,
but I was actually across the hall from
a professor who was doing a lot of the
research on fructose and obesity and
fatty liver disease and even he came to
the conclusion that if you overfeed
fruit dose and it creates a caloric
surplus and you're overfeeding for dose,
then you can have some wonky stuff start
to go on relative to other macros.
Die.
Try to keep this,
try to keep this right next to your
face.
Got It.
Cause that's what she said is so
powerful.
I talk loud and a lot.
It's good.
Um,
so if you're,
if you're doing that,
if you're creating that caloric surplus,
what you find is when you're in net
storage,
when you're driving more nutrients into
adipose and sometimes liver depending on
metabolism,
but it takes,
it takes a lot of fructose to do that.
And a caloric surplus,
you start to create a lot of wonky stuff
going on.
The Mitochondria starts to become
dysfunctional and people make a big deal
about,
oh,
well you have,
we have claimed now that everything
causes,
uh,
obesity and type two diabetes.
For,
for first it was fats,
carbohydrates,
and there's actually a professors out
there who actually will claim the
protein gives you diabetes.
And it's type something for a second.
What I mean,
the Mitochondria becomes dysfunctional.
How does the Mitochondrial,
how does that happen?
Okay,
so I'm going to state for everybody that
I'm going out on a limb.
This is my opinion.
Okay?
If you look at the research on obesity
and diabetes,
what happens is you have everything
start to elevate in the bloodstream,
so if you measure like there was a
professor who thought that branch chain
amino acids were causing obesity because
they were elevated in the blood stream
during or sorry,
during type two diabetes,
well yeah,
branched chain amino acids are elevated,
so fatty acids,
so triacylglycerides,
so as glucose,
so is it really those things causing it
or is it possible that when you are
overfeeding relative to what you burn
relative to that turnover,
that Mitochondria start to become
dysfunctional?
Probably a lot due to inactivity and the
Mitochondria is,
as we call it,
the powerhouse of the cell.
As you probably learned in high school
biology or whatever they taught it to
you as that is where everything fluxes
through.
So that is where you're creating ATP.
That's where you're burning through
lipids,
carbohydrates,
that sort of thing.
If that becomes dysfunctional and you're
not getting in a flux enough pull
through that Mitochondria,
what happens is you start to back up
every part of metabolism,
so all the metabolic byproducts,
almost all of them inhibit everything
within the cell.
There's a metabolomic signature for that
and Epi phenomenon,
if you want to call it that would be
elevated branched chain amino acids
because the consequence of that and some
people,
so these things start these byproducts,
these metabolic byproducts,
because you're not flexing enough
through the cell.
They start accumulating within the cell
and start to inhibit the krebs cycle
glycolysis and so everything starts
backing up to the point where you also
start inhibiting the insulin receptor
and now you have glucose,
fatty acids and amino acids.
Also backing up to the point where they
start to overspill into the bloodstream
and you see these,
this accumulation of all of them in the
bloodstream in type two diabetes.
And I actually think that again,
me going out on a limb that obesity
doesn't cause type two diabetes and type
two diabetes doesn't cause obesity.
That they develop in concert from the
same problem,
which is overfeeding under activity,
so a lot of it is about how much
nutrients you're fluxing into cells
versus how much energy you're creating.
Fluxing them through the cell on out,
so when you're overfeeding,
whether it be carbohydrate,
fat,
your fluxing more energy in than you can
dispose of,
and now you have to do something with
it.
Well,
when you run out of,
when you do that much to it and
Mitochondria start to become
dysfunctional,
you start to not have enough places to
put it away and it starts spilling into
the bloodstream and now you cause all
kinds of problems.
So one of the things that we really
wanted to talk about here is high carb
versus low carb because this is a just a
giant point of contention today.
Nutrition,
especially in terms of athletes with
performance in mind.
That's a big factor.
Whether or not high carb or low carb is
the way to go.
And there's a lot of zealots on both
sides and there's a lot of bullshit and
there's a lot of online experts.
And one of the great thing about
bringing you two guys in here is because
you could really actually explained the
science behind it.
Now you've been great lane at pointing
out that there's,
it's not a magic bullet and you know,
and so many people like to sort of
stress it that way,
that they,
they like to portray ketogenic diet is
this,
is it,
this is the end all,
be all.
I figured out what to do.
This is the way everyone should be
eating.
You don't think so?
I don't think so,
because if you look at the weight loss
problem in our society,
uh,
and I'm,
I'm writing a book called fat loss
forever.
When I talk about this in detail,
we don't have a weight loss problem.
Six out of every seven people were able
to lose a significant amount of body
weight in their life who are obese or
overweight.
The problem is the weight regained
statistics are absolutely terrifying.
Uh,
within one year,
70 percent will put it all back on.
Within two years it's 85 percent.
Within three years it's 95 percent.
So that means diets have a 95 percent
failure rate and of those people,
one third to two thirds will add more
than they originally lost and this gets
kind of into Yoyo dieting and I talked
about that as well.
But the real problem is that people
don't stick to pick something that's
sustainable for them all the recert,
if there's one bit of research out there
that,
that we have that shows how to create
lasting weight loss.
And you look at the people who were the
five percent who actually keep it off,
uh,
it's that they pick something that's
sustainable,
whether it be key to genic,
whether it be low carb,
high or low fat,
whatever it is,
Vegan something that they can sustain
and make a lifestyle.
If,
because if you look at Meta analyses for
our listeners,
med analyses are,
are kind of a study of studies.
So they take researchers take studies
that have similar parameters and they
kind of lumped them together and they
look at,
okay,
what's the consensus amongst these
studies?
And they have advanced statistics.
They used to run this.
If you look at low carb versus low fat,
there's no difference in adherence
overall on the whole there's no
difference and there's no difference in
weight loss,
there's no difference in blood lipids,
even glycaemic control.
So there was a study where they met
analysis of,
I think it was 23 studies,
over 3000 people where they looked at,
okay,
if you control calories,
so calories are equated,
does low carb versus low fat make a
difference on weight loss,
glycemic control,
those sorts of things.
The key to genic diet.
So by definition we have an objective
biomarker that defines the ketogenic
diet is the only diet that actually has
something that you can measure in your
blood that say you're on this diet and
when your ketone levels are elevated,
that confers many different benefits,
uh,
that I believe can enhance adherence to
the Diet.
Before we get into the woods here,
I want to clarify one thing,
the difference between someone being on
a diet and being able to sustain it and
not being able to stand in gaining all
that weight back.
Isn't that a discipline issue?
Well,
partly,
but we kind of had to start looking at,
okay,
if we,
if we go in,
let me read,
let me read circle.
We have to find what requires the least
amount of discipline for somebody to
stick to.
Because discipline is,
is while some people have more,
some people have less.
Um,
it is a finite resource.
So when do we normally find that people
like kind of drop off whatever they're
doing.
It's when they're stressed out,
work,
stressing them out,
they're going through a divorce,
those kinds of things,
right?
That's where are our discipline kind of
wanes because we're trying to be so
disciplined for this other thing and
it's draining us.
So what happens with,
with diet is in people who are busy,
people who have a lot of stress in their
life,
that's where they really start
overeating.
So we have to find something that I look
at it.
Let's find something that requires the
minimal amount of,
of discipline for a person so that when
your life goes to absolute shit,
you can still stick to it.
And so for some people that is a very,
very individual thing and they see this
in the dietary studies that what works
for one person to create a deficit and
sustainable isn't the same way for
another person.
And Dom even commented on this about his
wife Chella,
she does much better on a higher ratio
of carbohydrates to fats.
Yeah,
I mean,
early
on it was obvious that she wasn't going
to change her diet at the time that we
met like 10 years ago,
most we,
I was really getting into this and I
really felt that for me at least,
uh,
but she would stop at checkers and get a
burger with a sugary drink it.
And she's tremendously carbon tolerance.
She was very skinny as a kid and she
tolerated a carbohydrate.
She's very carbohydrate tolerance.
Did I say intolerant?
Okay.
Uh,
yeah.
So,
and,
and you know,
if the Diet low carb I feel,
and maybe in key to genic,
putting it in under that umbrella works,
I think for up to 25 to 30 percent of
people,
uh,
especially at their carbohydrate
intolerant.
And I believe that it does that by
virtue of elevating Ketones,
shifting your,
uh,
the neuropharmacology of the brain,
for example,
it works through Grelin,
it works through,
there's new science emerging right now
showing that appetite regulation is
influenced a positively by a nutritional
ketosis in ways that were just starting
to learn.
Now what?
You can certainly feel it.
It's one of the things about the
ketogenetic diet.
When you're in that state,
all of a sudden you're just not hungry
to say there's not a,
an overwhelming need for food.
Yeah,
I'm,
I haven't had anything to eat today.
I mean,
when I was eating massive plates of
Pasta Twenty five years ago and I went
to this this long without food,
I would start getting shaky.
I would,
I would have a hypoglycemic response.
And I'm completely resilient to that.
And that has major implications for
military personnel being keto adapted,
not just for performance,
preventing seizures.
I think for a cognitive function too.
But you,
uh,
it's very liberating.
So meal frequency is not an issue.
So if you're in austere environments
where you have limited food
availability,
that becomes a major issue.
And if you're working as a scientist and
you can't,
you know,
you're working with animals,
you're doing experiments,
you don't have time to eat.
I need to maintain that cognitive
function.
I needed to be sharp,
you know,
with limited boot.
So it worked very good for me throughout
my professorship,
you know,
getting tenure and things like that
where I could just put more time and
energy into my work without having to
stop,
prepare a meal,
eat a meal,
clean up.
Like I think I wasted a lot of time
doing that when I was eating five to six
meals a day.
He said something that I think you've
called bullshit on before the phrase
carb intolerant.
So yeah.
So that was actually going to be one of
the things that could say,
hey,
we have something we can disagree about.
Carb tolerance,
carb,
carb.
Would you would say how we define that?
Yes.
So if you have to find it by a blood
marker,
your glucose response to a meal.
Okay.
So a couple of things.
I want to come right out and frame this
whole discussion real quick.
So we both agree that in terms of weight
loss and body composition,
that your total calorie intake per day
is the most important thing,
correct?
Yes.
I believe the key to genic strategy is a
way to regulate that,
right?
So with,
with carbon tolerance,
if,
if you look at the benefits of like on
blood glucose,
blood lipids,
it is almost 90 to 95 percent explained
by weight loss.
So you can take people put them on a
high carb,
very low fat diet,
their blood glucose in their blood,
lipids will drop,
eat even with like higher insulin levels
than people who are in a a low carb diet
if they're on a calorie restricted
calorie restricted.
Now again,
that that becomes a very individual
thing.
I,
you know,
if somebody says,
hey,
I like a ketogenic diet because for me
it helps me to create a calorie deficit.
I can stick to it,
hey,
knock yourself out.
That is no problem.
But that is not always gonna work.
Some people don't feel that satiated on
a ketogenic diet.
There are people who do feel hungrier on
that.
So that is a very individual response.
And again,
when we look at studies we're looking at
means,
right?
So we're talking about averages and
there are outliers,
like if you look at any Gaussian
distribution chart,
which is kind of how populations
distributed based on a certain
treatment,
you have about 60 to 70 percent that
fall into the,
the average.
Then you have another,
you know,
10,
20 percent that are kind of do a little
bit better one way versus the other.
And then you have five percent on either
end that are,
sorry,
two and a half percent on either end
that are outliers.
Right?
So just to frame this again,
let's take weightlifting.
We know weightlifting makes you bigger
and stronger,
right?
Like that is not up for debate.
We agree on that.
There are studies that have shown that
some people who are beginners,
where you should be gaining a lot of
muscle very quickly,
uh,
some people will go from the first time
they walk into the gym Squat Ninety
Five,
12 weeks,
they're,
they're squatting 400 pounds.
Some people don't get stronger.
They've actually been.
Studies were over 12 weeks.
There is a few individuals who did not
get stronger,
so those are your outliers right there.
So if we circle this back to Ketogenic
Diet,
I'm not sitting here and saying that
somebody may actually physiologically do
better on a ketogenic diet versus a a,
a lower fat diet.
That's a very individual response,
but when we start making recommendations
for people,
what we should start with is okay
created calorie deficit that allows you
to lose some weight because if we look
at the studies and we look at if we
equate for protein,
because that's a big thing.
So if you look at some of the studies
were Volec did where he compared like,
uh,
you're kind of food guide pyramid type
diet to a ketogenic diet.
The ketogenic diets were a little bit
higher protein.
That protein has a thermogenic effect
and also an appetite suppression effect
when you equate for those.
And there's been 32 studies,
there was a recent med analysis done of
32 studies and acquainted for calories
and protein.
Absolutely no difference in fat loss
when you equate for those two calories
and protein because protein is a big one
because protein has a big benefit on
thermogenesis and weight loss.
Also a lean body,
mass retention,
which is huge because one of the reasons
people regain weight is because when
they lose weight,
they tend to lose fat and muscle and
when they regain it,
it's almost all fat in the initial phase
as far as
and may not have included data with the
key to genic diet.
So I know,
you know,
when I did the die,
I've seen a lot of blood work,
so for example,
my hemoglobin h,
one c,
triglycerides,
hs,
crp goes down,
insulin goes down,
blood pressure goes down,
and that,
that all those,
all those changes happened without my
bodyweight changing.
So that would kind of argue against
that.
You needed to catch us deficit.
Uh,
and I've seen it many times,
but once you could,
I could be eating 80 to 90 percent carbs
and reduced my body weight and get
changes in all that I could actually
increase my carbs.
And if I create a calorie deficit,
you know,
my hemoglobin h,
one c will go down,
my sugar will go down and things like
that.
So that is really the draw that's like,
that trumps everything,
that calorie deficit,
so that that's an important thing.
So that's what.
And that's what I think a lot of people
miss.
Okay.
I think that that,
what I'll say is.
Sorry,
I'm just saying like,
I think
it's very powerful too that these
changes that I just mentioned can occur
without a will,
without changing your body weight.
So they are just,
you know,
you're fundamentally changing your
metabolism when you do that from car.
And that has pretty wide ranging
implications.
So I think that what I'm going to say is
that if you,
if we're going to talk about people
getting healthier,
the first thing we need to start with is
let's not lose 50 percent are going
about five percent,
right?
So if I tell somebody,
hey,
find a diet,
you can stick to that sustainable.
And if you can lose 10 percent,
you can lose 10 percent of your body
weight.
Even for obese people,
they get almost all the health benefits
in the first 10 percent now.
Now maybe some people like you or people
who respond really well to a ketogenic
diet,
I'm not,
again,
there's outliers or people on the other
sides of the Gaussian curve.
If you do a little bit better on there
then great,
but if you find a ketogenic diet is
completely unsustainable for you and
you're not,
you're not able to stick to it,
but you're trying to do it because
you're trying to get a little bit better
blood glucose regulation.
You're,
you're,
you know,
you're kind of shooting yourself in the
foot because if you could stick to it,
like let's say for the individual,
a higher carb diet was easier for them
to stick to.
They could lose weight on that.
Then that's the bulk of their health
benefits they're going to get from it.
I'm having a hard time with these terms
easier because I don't know exactly why
it would be easier,
wouldn't be easier and I always wonder
again,
is this a discipline issue because
that's your experience.
Yeah,
it comes down for this,
for sure.
My
preference,
but I believe that by when you follow
low carb,
not even ketogenic diet,
the variability of the fluctuations in
your insulin and Blood Glucose,
the Postprandial dip in blood glucose
that you get after it,
that's virtually abolished or
significantly attenuated and then you
have a,
you know,
ketones are working through Grelin for
example.
You could just,
you could eat a normal diet and drink
ketones and it's actually suppressing
your appetite through Grelin.
So we know that these changes or
reductions in and you're saying,
yeah,
okay,
so um,
so these changes are happening,
but they're,
my sister for example,
you know,
follow the Ketogenic Diet and found it
easy to follow.
But she gained weight because she was
eating all these fat bombs that she was
making.
So she far and a lot of people don't
necessarily need a nutritionist to tell
them what to do,
but they needed like a nutritional
psychotherapist or something,
you know,
their,
their relationship with food is really.
And I think that's what lane has a firm
grasp on.
There's no substitute for experience.
And Lane has worked with so many
different clients and knows that,
you know,
you could probably follow the cue j dot
your listeners are probably fans of die.
I can do it.
I love fatty food,
you know,
a high fat food look our food.
But generally speaking it's,
you know,
you have to approach it from the
perspective of sort of eating behavior.
And I think that that's really.
People want to go off the Diet.
It's just a natural human trait.
Yeah,
it's a weird psychological trait,
right?
You just want to cheat.
You want to just stuff your face with
cupcakes every now and then.
And then you just feel like it's too
much torture to keep yourself on this
narrow path of high fat,
low carb,
moderate protein.
But you know,
years ago,
10 years ago that was the case.
But now there is key to genic brownies
or cookies.
There's many different food companies
like shirt
got chicken.
I've tried,
I tried so hard.
Go to Quito.
I have a real one and a kito cookie and
then fucking real fucking gets eaten
every time.
Yeah,
well they,
they are evolving.
Just,
you know,
food technology and evolving some of
them,
no foods,
make some good stuff.
Go to go to Quito,
nutrition.org.
And there's some things there that I
would say about 10 or 20
percent passed the test,
meaning that they taste okay and they
actually do what they say they actually
elevate ketones or you know,
don't call it the glycine
on some of those Keto Kookies seem like
they have no foundation.
Like you bite in the Galway,
like as you're eating them,
it's like they dissolve.
Do you have like a good toll house
cookie,
a good real chocolate chip cookie and
you bite into that soccer,
you know,
it's bad for you.
But God damn it feels good while it's
being tried.
The quest protein cookies.
Yes.
They're pretty good.
Yeah.
Pretty good.
They can't fuck with real cookies.
Yeah.
Well I dip.
I dip them in,
in like sour cream,
right?
And then I eat them or coconut cream so
that then it becomes good to just get a
commitment to a life that you bring that
up.
Interesting though.
Um,
if you look at people that think they're
addicted to sugar,
that sugar is a lot.
If you look at things like cookies and
cakes and it's actually they have more
calories from fats than they do sugars.
It's sugar and fat together
is hyper palatable.
But so we know one of the things I was
going to bring up as,
um,
you know,
this idea that the sugar is so
inherently bad and you said that the
cookie,
you know,
we view that as an inherently bad thing.
But what if I told you that a certain
people,
not everybody,
everybody's different,
but there are certain people who,
if you tell them,
hey,
you can have that cookie every once in a
while if you track it,
work it into your macronutrient intake,
that that's fine,
that,
that actually improve their adherence to
diet.
So because you give them a reward,
no,
not a reward system.
You're not a dog,
don't reward yourself with food because,
because increased flexibility,
uh,
actually usually improves adherence.
So we see this actually with training to
a athletes are when you do a flexible
training model where they have to get in
a certain amount of training,
but they kind of can pick and choose
yourself,
which days are hard and which days are a
little bit they actually do better.
Diet is very similar to that.
So now you always have to sacrifice
something in order to,
uh,
if you want to lose weight,
right?
So if you're doing a ketogenic diet,
what you're sacrificing is saying,
well I like the spontaneous reductions
in appetite,
so I don't mind eating these foods so I
can get that if you're doing like kind
of what,
I don't want to say I popularized it,
but myself and some other people on the
message boards popularized something
called flexible dieting where you can
eat essentially whatever you want as
long as you hit your protein,
carbohydrate and fat targets.
Now what you're sacrificing is okay.
You're tracking every day.
Do you do that through an APP?
Through what?
An APP?
Uh,
no,
I'm old school.
I actually just do it through excel.
I've my girlfriend holly,
she has an app on her phone and she,
she has me like if she's driving,
said,
oh well you put in what I just ate.
I'm like,
Babe,
I don't even know.
I have no idea how to work this thing.
You know?
So because when I went to do my graduate
studies,
I mean I wanted to find magic foods.
I wanted to find something that would
say,
how else can you make a living?
You have to set yourself apart.
I mean if I'm over here saying it's hard
for me to sell what I,
what I do,
because I'm saying,
well,
everything in moderation and you got to
be diligent and you got to have these
behaviors and that doesn't sound sexy
when there's another guy over here
saying,
now bro,
it's just carbs.
I know what tablet isms complicated and
everything,
but it's just carbs.
You know,
when I started working with people and
I've worked with over 1500 people
coaching and nutrition online over the
past 13 years,
which actually probably taught me more
than my,
my phd did.
Um,
what I found was,
is that people were so different
individually in terms of what,
what made them tick,
you know,
now I feel like I should probably go
back and get some kind of interesting to
biologically what makes them tick or a
psychological,
both,
so I can't sit here and say by the
research that that carbohydrate versus
fat makes a difference on fat loss.
But what I can tell you is that some
people just seem to do better on lower
carb,
higher fat.
But also some people I with just seem to
do better with higher carb,
lower fat.
Now,
whether that's a psychological thing or
a physiological thing,
it's hard to tease out medically to.
I think we all have different snips,
you know,
that,
some people have suppressed fatty acid
oxidation pathways,
other are like screaming fast
metabolizers,
you know,
or fat or sugar metabolizers.
Yeah.
So,
but if you look at,
like I remember I had a conversation
with,
um,
with the,
the researcher Dr Nakamura at Illinois
who was doing some of that fructose
stuff when I was,
when I was a first year Grad student.
I said,
well,
it's this,
this high fructose corn syrup,
this is what's causing obesity.
Right?
And he's like,
well,
it's easy to over consume.
You know,
like if you take a soda and you drink
it,
you're not less hungry than you were.
Stopped,
very satiating.
He said,
but if you're,
if you're controlling your calories,
it doesn't seem to be more lysogenic
than comparable carbohydrate.
And I remember thinking,
well,
that can't be right.
All these people say that high fructose
corn syrup,
it was like the worst thing in the world
for you.
There was,
there was a few studies that really
changed my opinion on sugar.
Now the listeners are going to hear this
and think that I'm advocating for sugar.
I'm not,
not talking about in the context of a
calorie surplus,
a surplus than the ovary can,
which kind of explains the state of the
United States,
you know,
uh,
partly partly.
So if you look at sugar intake,
there's.
So this Kinda gets back to the
carbohydrate,
insulin obesity model.
Uh,
if you look at sugar intake over the
last 50 years,
100 years,
it went up very steadily with obesity
until around the mid nineties and then
it took a sharp dip while obesity
continued to climb.
And again,
that's just correlation data.
But if you do look at the overall
calorie intake versus obesity rates,
it's like an r squared of like point
nine four,
which is really,
he really sugar include high fructose
corn syrup.
Is that lumped into.
So this was added sugars,
this was added sugars,
but there was a study done by a
metabolic ward studies.
So again,
I'm gonna stop you there.
Are you saying that this is added
sugars,
not high fructose fructose corn syrup.
So when you talk about the graph of
consumption,
that sugar dropped off,
but high fructose corn syrup did not.
Is that our,
because that took over many of the
products.
So it's an increase in obesity,
but a decrease in sugar consumption.
But you're not saying a decrease in high
fructose corn syrup consumption.
So I don't know that I'd have to look
that up.
So here,
here's,
here's me being a scientist in saying
the three magic words,
I don't know that one of the last
conferences I went to showed that like
the rise over the last 10 to 15 years
like skyrocketing,
like high fructose corn syrup and sugar
was taken out.
High Fructose Corn Syrup is subsidized
but farmers a lot cheaper and more.
Would you agree that it's essentially
your body way?
Processes is essentially the same sugar
versus high fructose corn syrup cows the
calorie.
Well,
so sugar,
sucrose is 50 percent glucose.
Fifty percent fructose,
high fructose corn syrup is 55 percent
fructose,
45 percent glucose.
But if you're saying that that five
percent is what's creating obesity,
eh?
Now again,
psychologically,
some people just down sodas like it's
their job,
you know?
And if you're doing that,
especially as children,
that's a big,
big no,
no,
he kissed the Mexican kind with the cane
sugar kids now with high with
nonalcoholic fatty liver disease and
that did not exist.
But I would say that we've got a little
kid like kids from corn syrup.
I think it's due to an excess surplus
calories and those surplus calories
being high fructose corn syrup.
So if you're,
if you're used to eating a certain
amount of calories and you may,
and we back when we were actually
maintaining your weight back in the,
before the sixties,
we were reading about 2100 calories a
day.
That was the average.
Uh,
and now it's like 2,800
is the average consumption.
The United States amongst adults.
Um,
I think I eat a lot more than that,
but,
but you trained but you train and you
have a higher lean body mass.
So that's,
that's,
that's fine.
Now some people,
yeah,
we,
that's a whole other rabbit hole.
Um,
the,
if you,
if you start adding sodas in which
aren't satiating at all,
they don't positively affect your hunger
hormones.
Uh,
but you continue your same normal food
intake.
Boom.
I mean,
you can start to store,
right?
Yeah.
So,
but I can't tell somebody,
hey,
there's no way you can lose weight and
drink a soda because that's not true.
Um,
there was a study done by a servlet and
they looked at high-glycemic a diet
versus low glycemic,
and I mean extreme.
They did a,
one group had over 100 grams of sugar a
day.
Another group had a 10 grams or less per
day are sorry,
it was 11 grams or less per day and they
looked at the differences in weight
loss,
blood lipids,
all that kind of stuff.
Did that everyday for carbohydrates.
So the group that ate 10 grams of sugar
or less a day to day eat the same amount
of total carbohydrates,
same amount of total carbs.
Okay.
So low-glycemic versus high-glycemic
processed carbs can spike your glucose
more than sugar.
Right?
So they did have a fire at higher fiber
intake.
But what the.
Well,
they did find that they had a higher
insulin responses to the meal.
The high sugar group did,
but no differences in weight loss.
So they,
both,
both groups lost weight.
Uh,
the only real difference was the,
the,
the lower glycemic group had a little
bit better.
Both groups improved,
improved cholesterol.
The lower glycemic group had just a
little bit better improvement probably
because they were eating higher fiber,
which can bind cholesterol and you
excrete it.
I would like to see what happened if
they equated.
So again,
it's,
it's creating that calorie deficit.
Both groups lost weight.
Now is it more difficult to create a
calorie deficit if you're eating a lot
of sugar?
Yes.
Okay.
So I always tell people your diet is
like a budget if you're practicing
something like flexible dieting.
Right?
So if I've got somebody like myself who
has above average muscle mass,
hopefully I can say that people on the
Internet probably going to do is wear a
shirt with his name on it.
So.
Okay,
I'll say it.
You have above average muscle mass.
Thank you.
You're welcome.
So,
so if you have above average last
semester,
you train hard,
you have a faster metabolism naturally.
I mean I've seen people who could
maintain their body weight on six,
7,000
calories a day.
You have a higher metabolic rate,
you have a really big budget.
So if you make $100,000,000
a year,
is it a big deal for you to go out and
buy a $500,000
sports car if you can still pay your
mortgage and pay all the other
requirements that you have?
No,
it's fine.
But if you make 80 grand a year,
should you go out and buy a $500,000
sports car?
Probably not.
Right?
And if you make 30 you should be on
Nikita.
Done.
Well you'd have increased for
deficiency.
So it's the same thing.
So like people up.
So pop tarts somehow became the model of
the flexible dieting movement because
people were,
here's why it's Kinda like
counterculture.
So pop tart zealots out there.
It's like,
so whenever you have.
So clean eating became a thing amongst
bodybuilding's,
we say eat clean even though there's no
objective,
there's no objective definition of that.
Um,
so people were like,
Oh yeah,
well I'm getting shredded night pop tart
everyday.
Right?
So a lot of your followers do that.
They do now.
Now I don't even like pop tarts.
He'd be honest.
Did you start this?
No,
no,
no.
It's not,
I don't know who else.
Hang on,
let me,
let me put the context of this so it's
more about people saying,
hey,
I can still eat these foods I enjoy and
I'm still losing weight because I'm with
it.
I'm in a calorie deficit and I'm hitting
my protein,
carb and fat targets,
but if you're somebody with a slow
metabolism and you're not exercising
very much and maybe all you're eating is
100 grams of carbs a day,
should you spend 75 grams of those carbs
on two pop tarts?
Hell No.
That's a terrible idea because you're
not going to be able to hit your other
micronutrients and those sorts of
things,
but if you're eating 4,000
calories,
like an Alberto Nunez friend of ours,
if you're eating 4,000
calories,
date and losing weight,
is it a big deal?
If he has to pop tarts?
Not really because he actually had one
competitor.
Again,
a competitor who had such a fast
metabolism that he was actually having a
lot of gi dysfunction because he,
he,
he was eating like 700 grams of carbs in
200 grams of fat per day just to
maintain his weight and he said,
I,
I feel bloated all the time.
And I said,
well,
what are you eating?
Like what are your foods?
And it was chicken,
rice and Broccoli,
and I said,
it's a peanut butter for fats.
And I'm like,
well,
no wonder dude,
you're having 150 grams of fiber a day.
You're literally full of Shit.
Like your shit is like literally backed
up to your esophagus.
Okay.
So I said,
do me a favor,
eats and pizza,
eat some pop tarts,
eat some more calorically dense foods
and see how you felt for three days.
He emailed me after three days,
he was like,
man,
I feel so much better.
I dropped like three pounds.
I feel amazing because he doesn't make
any sense because he got fired.
The pop tart generation.
Uh,
he also inspired and I watched this play
out online and she sounded really bad.
Well,
lane actually inspired a generation of
drug free bodybuilders to go and do
their phds,
you know,
and uh,
actually one's in my lab right now,
man,
student Andrew for a little while.
Yeah,
amazing student and I think he,
he learned a lot just from watching lane
or so,
uh,
but I think,
you know,
that it was amazing to see these guys
eating that amount of pop tarts and junk
foods and Bob and I learned a lot from
that,
but I think they could do it with,
with better carbohydrates.
So.
So what works for performance,
what works for bodybuilding may not be,
is probably not optimal for longevity
and health.
So that's an important point.
You know,
lean winds.
I,
yeah,
the audio is okay.
So I know where he's coming from,
but you know,
I'd like to hear his opinion.
Yeah.
So before you do that,
why do you think that it would be an
issue?
What would be the issue with sugar and
with pop tarts and junk food?
What will be the negative effects?
Biologic?
I think the accumulation of the Post
Prandial spikes in glucose and insulin
over time,
especially in the context of a calorie
surplus,
could be a bad thing.
If you are doing a calorie surplus to
example,
for example,
to gain weight and mass over time,
which bodybuilders do following contest
in the off season,
uh,
I think it's even more important almost
to actually stick with foods,
carbohydrate sources that are lower
glycemic.
You know,
you can only tolerate so much fiber.
But I think if you are running a
calories or if you are doing a ketogenic
diet and you have a calorie surplus,
that could be a bad thing.
Your triglycerides,
your triglycerides will go up.
So you are,
you're putting too much fat in the
system and that what it would go up on a
higher carb diet,
higher carb diet too.
So,
I mean I kind of would stay along the
lines of maybe protein,
but you just,
you titrate it in,
in a reasonable amount.
But I just think that the negative,
you know,
that could come out of that is that
you're,
you know,
I'm following a blood glucose curve,
right?
And insulin curve,
and,
and I see this very dramatically,
for example,
my student who is a type one diabetic,
Andrew [inaudible],
who's in and he wears a Dexcom
continuous blood glucose monitoring
system and his insulin requirements
dramatically dropped with low carb and
his glucose fluctuations dramatically
improved.
And that's going to pay big dividends
probably if you have type one diabetes,
you ever,
you know,
the 10 top things,
uh,
on,
on how humans die,
you have a greater risk for every one of
those,
you know,
dramatic cuts 10 years off your life if
the tighter you can keep your glucose
levels,
your blood glucose and your insulin
levels that in the long run I feel it's
going to pay.
Big Science still has to show that
I think it's not totally clear,
uh,
but I think we can for type one
diabetics,
which I think we can apply that data to
the,
to the population if they control their
glucose levels,
that pays big dividends in the long run
lane.
So a couple things.
Yes.
You touched on a couple of points I was
going to bring up,
but I want to address one thing first,
which is a,
the higher post Prandial insulin in
those negative effects on health.
Um,
so if you have,
they've done studies on this,
on BMI versus insulin.
Now Bmi as a,
we can debate about how useful a measure
it is,
but in general it reflects body fat in
the average population,
not lifters,
but in the average BMI,
by the way,
for people who are listening is a ratio
of your height versus your weight that
generally reflects obesity and you're
obese.
I'm so,
if you lift weights,
I'm morbidly obese.
It seems so silly.
It is.
But if you look at the general
population who doesn't exercise,
it's actually pretty darn accurate.
Um,
gets factored into your insurance,
which is not as it relates to your can
look at you and say some bs.
Some insurances will do like a waist to
chest measurement,
which,
which helps,
but anyway,
so post Prandial Insulin,
they've looked at the relationship
between people who have their BMS and
post prandial insulin.
They find that people with higher BMI
have higher post Prandial insulin,
but the opposite relationship does not
hold true for people who have higher
insulin,
do not necessarily have higher bmi and
they've done this in med analysis.
So what that says is again,
that if you are obese type two diabetic
metabolic syndrome profile,
that you will have elevated levels of
insulin because your body's becoming
insensitive to it because of all the
dysfunction that we talked about,
but just because you secrete higher
insulin doesn't mean that you're going
to have more body fat.
And there was a study done actually by
one of the proponents of the
carbohydrate insulin hypothesis,
um,
that looked at what's called Mendelian
randomization where basically the idea
is you have different gene variants like
we were talking about.
And if,
for example,
like they've done this with ldl
cholesterol are.
Sorry,
yes,
ldl cholesterol.
We believe most people believe the ldl
cholesterol has some contribution
towards heart disease.
It's a pretty,
I would say it's a pretty strong now.
People can over controversial text
dependent and individual.
When they look at these,
these gene variants,
people who have gene variants where they
run lower ldl,
have lower rates of heart disease,
people who are higher heart rates.
If you look at that with insulin at
best,
insulin explains 10 percent of obesity
at absolute best and that study actually
showed that high level of bias.
It was between one to 10 percent.
So we're not,
I'm not putting out the,
the idea that maybe insulin has some
effect talking about fasting or post
Prandial
insulin.
Oh,
overall,
I,
I'm guessing probably more so fasting.
How did they measure insulin?
I mean we,
we have hemoglobin h,
one c for like uh,
you know,
so there was another unit that,
there was another med analysis where
they looked at a higher carb versus
lower carb diets,
equating calories,
looking at Hba one c and saw that.
So the,
the differences in weight loss,
we're no different like we've discussed
when calories are acquainted,
but also the differences in Hba.
One C reduction were different.
They were the same.
Now you asked about health and you know,
consuming some of these quote unquote
bad foods.
If you do it in the but you said in the
context of a caloric surplus,
right,
which is the important thing because
they helped to create a surplus,
but in a deficit that what's the
downside?
Because kind of when you talk to people
who were not,
not ketogenic necessarily,
but proponents of quote unquote clean
eating,
which again has no real objective
definition when you say,
okay,
well a pop tart,
maybe you can lose weight up,
it can't be good for you.
Okay,
well then we have to have some objective
measurement to show this by,
right?
Like because otherwise it's.
Do you believe in magic?
Okay,
so if you look at processed foods,
what they have found with processed
foods is that you have a lower energy
expenditure from them.
Okay,
so you have a certain amount of what we
call t e,
f thermic effective food.
A higher protein has a higher t f than
carbohydrate and fat.
Okay?
So we know the higher protein diets
actually cause more weight loss and
better lean body mass protection.
Part of that is through the increase
thermogenesis of,
of the TF thermic effect of food.
Well,
with processed foods,
you have a lower tef okay,
but that doesn't mean you can't eat any
processed foods and,
and lose weight you can eat,
just means you might have to eat a
little bit lower calories overall.
Does that make sense?
There was a key to genic pop tart and it
was made with,
with almond tastes like shit.
We know that if we amens were probably,
you know,
other nuts or things just given an
example,
you know,
we don't fully digest,
assimilate and utilize those calories.
They pass through us.
So with the pop tart,
uh,
I think it's pretty high with like raw,
like,
like a salad with nuts and things like
that.
Like it becomes significant over time
with the pop tart,
like you can basically 100 percent of
that is going into your system and it's
causing a hormonal response.
So the food that we eat creates is not
only calories but creates a hormonal
response and also from the brain
perspective can change the
neuropharmacology of your brain.
I mean,
that's how I got into the key to genic
diet because it fundamentally changes
neurotransmitter systems and reward
systems.
And things like that,
right,
but hormones,
people get so hung up on hormones and
and if you look at the research data
just doesn't support it.
Like with Insula,
whatnot.
Now in terms of like losing weight and
you're,
you're what happens with Leptin and
Ghrelin and all those kinds of things.
That is a huge.
One of the.
One of the things we talked about before
the podcast started,
we had about a 30 minute podcast and we
did actually,
you know,
people say things like,
one of the reasons people are really
mistrustful of kind of the calories in
calories out model is because it is
viewed as a to isolated variables,
calories in,
calories out or separate.
That's not true.
Calories in effects.
Calories out.
Okay.
There are a moving target.
So people will say,
well I ate in a calorie deficit and I
didn't lose weight.
No,
you ate and what you thought was a
calorie deficit and you didn't lose
weight,
but if you didn't lose weight,
it was not a calorie deficit by
definition.
Okay.
So retaining water or something.
Yeah.
Who's when we look at dieting,
like just dieting in general over time
lowers your metabolic rate,
right?
So if you take somebody,
they actually did a rat study.
Again,
rats,
but rats tend to respond pretty similar
to humans into.
Would you agree with that in terms of
blood?
I mean,
you do a lot of rats,
rats and mouse studies.
Uh,
yeah,
I,
I think there's a lot of overlap there.
Yeah,
they're good model.
So again,
when we have to put that out there
because we want to,
we don't want to oversell it.
They did A.
depends on the context of what you're
studying.
Of course,
like you don't want it to be like animal
studies can be helpful,
but you don't want to do like an insulin
study in cows because cows are ruminants
in there.
They don't care about insulin anyway,
they took rats,
they took them to,
to diet cycles.
Okay.
So this is kind of back to the Yoyo
dieting thing.
Um,
and they looked at okay and they took
obese rats of them down to a kind of
normal level than they,
than they basically gave him as much
food as they want to let him eat back to
the original obese level dye to them
down again to the previous level.
And then let him read back up.
What they found was absolutely
astonishing.
There are food efficiency with so far up
because their metabolic rate became
suppressed every time they died.
It down.
Your body has this self defense system
that you activate every time you dye it.
I talk about this in my shameless plug
book.
Um,
so the first time they died,
if that's the kind of one times rate
that they lost a fat ass,
when they let them regain it,
they regained it twice as fast as they
lost it.
Then the second time they tried to lose
it,
they lost it at half the original rate.
Then when they regained it,
the second time they gave you gained it
three times as fast their food
efficiency would weigh up the ability to
lose it.
Have you noticed?
Well,
what's that?
Lucid get faster as well.
No,
no.
They took him twice as long to lose the
same amount of weight.
Sorry,
I probably didn't explain it very well.
Yeah,
I took him twice as long to lose the
same amount of weight and they regained
it in a third the time of the original.
So your body's getting accustomed to
famine.
Exactly.
Because every time you diet it,
and we see this with yo Yo dieters who
spend.
How many people do you know that seemed
to be perpetually on a diet,
but they just had that short overfeeding
period in between diets underneath.
It really does because every time you
died you're activating your body self
defense system.
How many fighters do you know that every
time they die it gets harder and harder
for them to make weight.
While they're doing more than that,
they're.
They're cutting weight.
The cutting weight is ruthless.
They're essentially almost dying.
Right?
But part of that is there.
They're having to crash diet super low.
So what is the signal you're telling
your body?
Because you have to always think about
things.
From an evolutionary perspective.
My Phd advisor was great about this,
he'd always asked his name,
was Dr Don Lemon,
brilliant guy,
and he would say,
why do you think the body did this?
Well,
if you think about what are the
regulatory mechanisms of becoming fat
versus becoming too thin?
Right?
So one,
one danger is you starve to death.
The other danger is you get so fat that
a Predator can come get you,
which is more dangerous in the last
20,000
years.
It's family,
it's family.
So your body creates much tighter
defense system there.
So when you diet,
your metabolic rate slows way down.
I mean if you've,
you've ever these guys who cut weight,
so by the time they're ready to get a
fight,
for example,
their metabolic rates really slow.
Then what happens after they fight,
they eat a crap ton of food because
they're there,
they're Grelin is way up,
Leptin is way down,
insulin is way down and they regain it
really fast.
Now,
what
to assume?
Just to interject that if you die it for
16 weeks for a show,
for example,
or a contest that what you actually
educated me in like 10 years ago and I
thought there was this like post contest
rebound and in two weeks there'd be this
anabolic window or whatever for fat.
It actually,
if you die hard for 16 weeks to make
way,
it takes an equal amount of time to get
your metabolism back actually to that
level.
Again,
maybe d.
So lane coined the term,
right?
Reverse dieting river,
I don't know if I call,
I pointed it and did this with metabolic
chambers and in rats.
And then use a variety of different
approaches to determine how fast it,
it actually takes to,
uh,
to bring your metabolism backup.
And if different strategies can be used
to ramp up your metabolism,
well,
because when you regain it,
you regain fat really quickly,
but your metabolic rate is more sluggish
to return.
So they actually did a study with the
biggest loser participants.
And this is why I'm so big on what is
sustainable that it has to be
sustainable.
They looked at um,
so they last on average,
like a quite a bit of weight,
I can't remember the exact numbers,
but they lost a bunch of weight over the
30 weeks because they starve them and
they exercised the crap out of them and
they saw that their metabolic rate
dropped 500 calories more than you would
predict just by the amount of body fat
and lean body mass they lose.
This is what's called metabolic
adaptation.
When you defined the metabolic rate
dropping,
what do you mean by that?
What's the.
So?
So you have.
So we can calculate all this stuff.
So your overall total daily energy
expenditure,
you're tde is made up of your basal
metabolic rate,
which is what you burn.
Like what we're doing right now just
sitting around doing oxygen consumption
car to production.
I actually actually to be real,
it's just laying down doing nothing.
So basically the energy you burn keeping
the lights on,
right?
That's one component.
It's about 50 to 60 percent in most
people.
Then you have your neat,
which is like this,
like I'm moving my hands,
I'm ambulatory movement,
non voluntary movement.
This stuff will actually go down when
you diet,
like if you've ever been around,
people will go down.
Yes.
You stopped fidget.
Spontaneous movement goes down.
It's a huge modifier.
So like if you look at either the DVD,
when I was prepping for a show back in
2010,
I blink slower.
I'm not kidding.
You and I talk slower.
Yeah.
Mind you were like on volume.
It looks like you're.
You're right.
Now I'm all hyped up on in the life of
lane with that says,
oh absolutely.
Like you're so your body,
this is your body genic di would help
you.
So.
So when you think about.
So there's neat.
That's that.
Then your exercise activity,
which is intuitive,
that's how many calories you burn
exercising,
and then there's what's called the
thermic effect of food,
which we already discussed.
How much energy required to get energy
out of food.
Okay.
And all those add up to your total daily
energy expenditure and we can predict
based on equations how,
what your metabolic rate should be.
So these people,
their metabolic rate was 500 calories a
day lower than it should have been.
Just based off the weight they lost
because if you lose muscle and lose fat,
you have less weight to carry around,
right?
So your metabolic rate goes down just
from that,
but it goes down way more than it
should.
That is your.
The first prong of your body self
defense system to stop you from starving
yourself is to become more efficient.
We hear the word efficiency and we
think,
wow,
that's.
That's a good thing.
Think about if your body fat levels were
a gas tank and you have.
You had a car,
okay.
You would not want to be efficient,
right?
You to have one of the old suburbans,
it was like half a mile per gallon,
right?
You don't want the Prius because you can
go way longer.
So going back to that study on rats,
they became so much more efficient with
their food,
and this is the second prong of your
body is self defense system is to not
only slow down your metabolic rate while
you're dieting,
but to start activating systems that
deal with restoring.
Once you actually start overeating
again.
Have you ever done a long diet or known
somebody who did it and then they start
eating again?
It's like everything sticks to you.
It's like you just.
It's like you like,
how did I gain five pounds from one day
and people are like,
oh,
it's water.
Well,
water doesn't stay around for six
months,
so it's not water that is your body
preparing all these systems,
so even like enzymes that deal with fat
storage while you're dieting actually go
up because it's preparing your body for
restoring and then even probably the
most interesting thing is it all falls
back on the importance of tracking
Macros,
which is completely ignored with guys
coming off of a fight or fitness
competitors.
Let yourself blow up really quickly.
It's a myth that your body is set up to
be anabolic or to gain muscle.
That is for your setup for fat.
Yeah,
but the point I'm trying to make is that
the way most people diet,
which is this kind of.
I mean,
you know,
you've probably been around people who
do this stuff.
It's a lot of people,
they they pick the next fad diet.
Whatever's popular,
they do it,
they lose some weight and the navy gain
it.
My Dad lost 30 pounds on a ketogenic
diet,
regained 50 right now.
The real problem is in the macros.
Now he does,
but the real problem,
and he's down 50 pounds again,
but the real problem is if we used to
think adipose tissue is like a sponge,
right?
So if you ate too much,
you just threw more in there,
right?
Soaked up extra nutrients,
and then if you started,
if you're in a caloric deficit,
you were losing weight.
It just gave up some of its nutrients.
You know,
like the guy who fasted for 365 days and
didn't die because he had so much,
so much fat.
We now know that body fat fits every
definition of a,
of an inadequate system.
It's a tissue.
It is an actual organ because it sends
out hormonal signals,
it integrates hormonal signals,
it talks to the brain,
the Hindbrain,
the arcuate nucleus is integrated in all
of metabolism in a big way,
and typically you have.
The way we gain fat,
lose fat is based on the fat cell size.
So you have a set number of fat cells
and the other expand,
or they shrink pretty intuitive,
unless now you can create more fat
cells.
If you become so obese that you
literally can't stuff any more fat in
there,
right?
So obese people have fat cell
hyperplasia.
A lot of times what's really interesting
is people at the end of a diet when
your,
when your thyroid hormone is lower,
your sympathetic nervous system tone is
lower.
This unique hormonal.
May Lou,
if you overfeed to rapidly,
there's a researcher named Mclean out of
Colorado that actually showed that you
can actually increase your fat cell
number if you overfeed to rapidly right
after a diet.
Now,
this was in rats,
full disclosure,
but it was fascinating stuff.
Now you're increasing your body's,
but it makes sense from an evolutionary
perspective.
Your body's like,
shit,
we had this famine.
We don't want to deal with this shit
again.
We want to make sure that we can store
as much stuff as possible,
so we're going to create some new.
This dude is rapidly overfeeding.
We're going to create some new fat cells
to make sure we're not going to miss any
of this energy.
We're going to capture every single bit
of it.
I like what you're saying and it makes a
lot of sense.
You're talking about weight loss and
weight gain,
but you were specifically discussing
hormonal changes in the body due to the
ketogenic diet that are beneficial and
that these hormonal changes and the
changes to the way the brain functions
would be a benefit of following that
diet versus just working on calories.
Yeah,
I mean it's at that book I gave you the
complete book of Ketones by Dr Marion.
So,
uh,
so that,
I don't think it's actually out yet
because prep guide going to get jacked.
So ketones are hints of Beta.
There a,
a,
there are sort of,
by definition have a metabolic
superiority as a,
as a fuel source,
you know,
and they readily cross the blood brain
barrier.
They can largely replace glucose as the
primary energy source in your brain
under periods of fasting a or ketogenic
diet.
So that,
that offers a lot of advantages to
someone dieting because it makes you
resilient.
Like the guy that fast at 382 days,
his glucose was,
was like 30 and dipped down the 20.
That would be universally fatal for most
people.
But as ketones were elevated,
so he did not feel hunger.
So that,
that is true.
Like the Cahill Studies,
George Cahill,
a studies at Harvard medical school
where they fasted subjects for 40 days,
they injected insulin to increase what
are,
did two that I remember presenting this
Atliens camp a while back.
Uh,
and I,
when I,
you know,
read this study,
I had to call him on the phone,
he was living,
he passed away in 2012,
but we had a number of conversations
before he passed away and I was amazed
that he got ethics approval to do that
because it's basically like killing
someone injecting 20 I use of insulin.
But what was fascinating that they were
asymptomatic for hypoglycemia at a level
of hypoglycemia that's typically
universally fatal.
And they were also a very cognitively
lucid.
And that was a dramatic demonstration at
the time it was thought that,
you know,
the brain could only use glucose.
So this is a paradigm shift in the way,
uh,
we understand sort of fuel utilization
and particularly in the brain,
so that has major and I can go on and
talking about the different applications
of the Ketogenic Diet,
which I did on the first podcast.
But from a perspective of someone
dieting to lose weight dieting as a
lifestyle,
doing intermittent fasting,
the key to genic diet makes intermittent
fasting much easier because your brains
adapted to it.
That for me had tremendous,
a practical applications that allowed me
to excel through academia.
I was able to do a lot more work,
not get hungry.
And uh,
and you know,
Lena,
we haven't trained in a while,
but when we train last night we did dead
lifts.
I mean we were doing both deadlifting
six 75 for reps and I was on,
actually,
I was on the,
the,
uh,
the classical ketogenic diet then that's
when I was just doing it and it out to
your school versus like an 80 to 90
percent fat.
And I was doing that for about a year
and um,
you know,
dead lifting like three times my body
weight for,
for Reps,
you know,
and it didn't hurt me.
I can't say that would be the case for
everyone,
but I also titrated the calories in that
I wasn't really at a calorie deficit.
I lost a little bit of ways.
So I guess by definition I was at a
calorie deficit now for people that are
thinking about gains,
trying to gain weight,
they would think that the key to genic
at that 80,
90 percent fat would not be enough
protein.
I believe that the ketogenic diet shines
when you are in a calorie deficit.
I,
my mentor for the cancer work,
Tom Seyfried had published a study
showing an unrestricted ketogenic diet
can actually promote cancer growth in a
brain tumor model.
Unrestricted meaning too much calories.
Yeah.
They were feeding mice a sugary at key
to genic formula that was on the market
at the time.
Well,
it was a sweetened.
I'm sorry.
It was sweet and cute.
Agentic formula with hydrogenated fats
and other things.
Yeah,
it was a,
as sweetened with maybe with aspartame
or something like that,
so they might tend to overeat it and
when they overeat it,
you know,
it creates a plethora of metabolic
abnormalities and uh,
you also get those same mountain rallies
when you over eat carbs.
You didn't say,
here's me being,
just as a side note,
how much does it drive you guys crazy
when you hear about this fat acceptance
thing or fat is healthy when you be fat.
So much of this going around to
massively obese people,
they're trying to say it's okay,
it's fine.
You're your football players,
right?
I mean,
by definition they're pretty healthy.
I mean they,
they lift,
they train a metabolically,
their bloodwork kind of looks okay,
so you have guts,
but they're not surprise you with my
answer.
Okay.
Uh,
so,
uh,
we talked about this earlier,
I'll take the heat.
I'm a libertarian,
so if somebody says I'm fat and unhappy
and I liked my life and I know what the
risks are that I say,
knock yourself out.
I've ended up before the judge will make
somebody else happy.
But now the problem is if you complained
about being fat,
that you got to do something about it,
otherwise you're not going to have any
patients for.
That goes back to the discipline there,
but you can be fit,
but fat that you.
Because you have morbidly obese people.
Like I said,
if you lose 10 percent of your body
weight,
there's overweight people who run
marathons.
Texture.
Yeah.
You can't tell me they're not in shape.
Yeah,
no,
know for sure.
It's just you're just carrying extra
weight.
I mean,
look at Daniel Cormier.
He's not obese.
He's not obese,
but he has some fat.
Don't come get me down.
I thought steep meo chick.
He was more than 40 pounds over his
fighting weight as a light heavyweight
champion and he was actually heavier
than steep a bay and serves the
practical friend of mine.
But yeah,
but that is.
The performance is not the same thing as
aesthetics.
Let me tell you what it meant to shape
what I looked like.
That I looked amazing.
You felt like shit.
I felt like shit ready to pass out.
Literally for me to stand up was a.
was I remember being on the couch and
there was a stupid,
some show on [inaudible] dot com.
Uh,
there was a stupid show on TV and the
remote was,
this goes back to neat.
There was a remote over there,
like five feet away.
I sat and watched the whole show because
I just didn't feel like getting the
fucking remote.
So isn't it ironic because you look so
good,
like when you jacked
like that,
you look like you just fucking running
forever breakthrough walls.
Now there is a threshold,
like you know,
some of the Ray Williams who is the
world's best power lifter.
I mean he looks obese,
dude squats legit 180 pounds.
Isn't that an issue there with power
lifter?
So a good percentage of them carrying
around a lot of body fat.
It's not as much as you would think
anymore like in the super heavyweight ts
because like for example,
the IPF,
which is kind of the IOC recognized
Power Lifting Federation that I compete
in their cutoff for super heavy weights
to 65.
So if you're going to be a super
heavyweight,
might as well just be 3:50,
you know,
it was that Dude Jamie,
that's ray as bets re re look at the bar
bending.
Dude,
that's,
he's a beast.
He's a beast,
right?
Gentlemen,
Super Nice Guy,
a blind sumner,
another one.
But like when I sit my squat record of
six 68 at 200,
five pounds,
I mean I was in pretty good shape for
that,
but for me to get to like eight percent
body fat,
no problem for me to get from eight
percent and I'm calibrating.
So for me to get to from eight percent
to three percent,
so fucking nightmare your body again.
Really get down to three on.
I think that would be if you floated.
No,
there are no actual,
uh,
accurate measures of body fat.
That's the uh,
that's why it's not really like the
relatively within themselves.
They're activists dependent upon
hydration factors.
Yes.
So people,
not to make too much of a side tangent,
but people look at Dexa dual x Ray
absorption technology and they say,
oh,
that's the gold standard.
Texas actually really finicky.
Like I remember Dec,
seeing rats in studies that we do it in
duplicate,
so we do it twice and sometimes you'd
have like differences just decorating
the same rat twice.
It depends on the machine,
your hydration status,
because water,
if you want to gain,
you know what the best way to gain eight
pounds of lean body mass within five
minutes,
go do a Dexa,
then drink a gallon of water,
go back to the next,
another Dexa.
You'll be eight pounds.
Lean body mass heavier.
You can impress your friends because
it's the two compartment model.
More lean body mass.
It's a to compartment model.
Same thing with calipers.
It's only measuring your amount of fat
tissue.
So anything that's not fat is lean body
mass.
So if you guys are using that to track
progress,
if anybody use that to track progress,
it's only accurate relative to the
measurement.
So your calipers me nothing for what
your dexa measurements going to be and
vice versa.
I see it,
but the change,
like if I'm.
If I'm calibrating a consistently at 10
percent and then it drops to eight and
then seven and I can be relatively
confident that I'm losing body fat,
same thing for Dexa,
but you have to do it at the same time
of day,
same hydration status,
all of that kind of stuff.
And I don't really use dexhub because
people,
in order to get an accurate,
you'd have to use it like every day for
it to be actual relative.
You use pictures,
right?
So when he was dying and got to a
certain way off tangent here,
but I looked at him as,
okay,
yeah,
like stop there.
But then he would go for another and get
to a level where
he looked very gaunt.
I mean,
you looked what looks good.
They're like seeing him in person.
Like I need this personality was
changing.
I mean,
it's kind of Freaky,
disgusting.
Looking towards the end,
uh,
and many people who maybe follow the
sport but don't compete,
don't really realize what the difference
between five percent or six percent and
three percent is.
So that separates the competitors from
the.
That's your Bros online.
Really fighting evolution at that point
because your body is trying to,
your close to starvation,
literally your body is trying to keep
you from doing that,
so like you think about food all the
time,
you actually become.
So a friend of mine,
Chris Foster,
he's a professor at l a.
He was doing his phd at the same time as
me and him.
My other friend Dr Jeremy Lin and Dr
Lindy Russo,
Chris's wife Chris was doing a contest
prep,
but I prepped him for the show and it
was a six months study of He's a natural
bodybuilder,
so drug free and they looked at the
hormonal responses,
his weight,
his body fat and even like measures of
mood.
Chris is like the most.
I was a beast like to 60 or I'm not a
natural joy free by 2:20
in the off season,
but one day he just looked like he,
you know,
he's a big guy,
but he's like a very mellow dude by the
end.
His mood measurements.
We're measuring like that of a
psychopath.
Really?
Yeah.
It just changes your mood around
fighters who like they get when they get
that lean,
it's just like he could barely talk to
you and we'll think about.
Think about like they're actually trying
to peak for a fight at the same time.
They feel the most like shit.
It's ridiculous.
They're so focused on cardio they want
to make to send to a.
they're.
They're focused on just dehydration and
making that way.
I've seen some of the protocols.
I've.
There's some good ones out there,
but some of the stuff I've seen them
like,
God,
I wish I could talk to somebody in that,
in that realm because it's so.
It's so much bro.
Science,
it's so dangerous to.
And it's.
It's really,
you can only do it three or four times
and then your body starts to reject it
and these guys have to go up and wait.
Like you were talking about.
Well,
you explained to you why.
Yeah,
it.
Guess what?
What happens when they go up a weight?
Sometimes they start crushing it.
Do they do much better?
So it's testosterone right?
At plummeted,
but his,
his bazell requirements as calories
department was like 1200.
The crazy thing is I'm.
So,
there had been some critics of my,
my kind of a view of metabolic
adaptation.
The body is self defense system,
full full disclosure.
Some people criticized me about that.
They say,
well,
if you look at metabolic adaptation,
it only explains it's only a 15 percent
adaptation relative to the whole
adaptation.
And uh,
but if you look at Chris's numbers,
I think on average that's probably right
on an average diet with an average
person you take,
somebody's trying to get really lean or
somebody who jojo diets or somebody
crash diets.
And now you know,
if again,
it's proportionate.
If you challenge your body with
something extreme,
it's going to respond in an extreme
fashion.
So every case study we have on natural
bodybuilders and there's about 10 of
them now who look at their contest
preparation and coming out of it.
And I use them to just because this is
the realm I grew
up in,
shows that they're hypogonadal by the
time that they're at stage.
So hypogonadal meaning their
testosterone,
their testosterone is clinically low.
Yeah,
naturally.
And these are guys like me.
I actually run.
I actually have a pretty naturally high
testosterone level.
Like when every.
Every time ever since I'm 16 years old,
when I got tested,
I've been like over 800.
If I'm eating enough.
When I was at contest,
I was under 300.
This is part of how your body fights
you.
Your body does not want you to be that
lean,
but if you're kind of raining this back
into the discussion,
this is why I talk about why it's so
important to pick something that's
sustainable for you as an individual.
Because if you do this shit where you
Yoyo Diet or you don't come out of it
appropriately,
it will fuck you up.
I mean we've.
We've all females,
especially in a lot of track record,
like I,
I've worked with a lot of females now
because especially in physique sports,
there's a lot of really bad coaching
starvation diets than for women.
It's,
it just messes with their reproductive
cycle to stop having peer mentors,
which I'm going to and of itself doesn't
seem to have necessarily what does that
no menstrual cycle.
So it doesn't necessarily end of itself,
seemed to be a,
um,
have negative health consequences in
terms of longevity or disease or
anything like that.
But yeah,
I mean if you can't get pregnant,
I mean that's a big deal for some women,
but the women don't want to hear is you
may have to gain some body fat to get
that back.
You know,
they don't want to hear that.
But this is why,
like I really start with sustainability
and then from there I go to,
okay,
what?
So if we've got what's sustainable for
you now,
can we get a little bit better?
Can we do a little bit more fiber?
Like I think in general,
you know,
I criticize Paleo diets because I think
their validation for their model is
absolutely fucking stupid.
Oh,
the kind of evolutionary validation and
the fact that we didn't drink milk and
we didn't eat beans in this kind of
thing,
but coffee.
But the question shouldn't be what we
were doing.
The question should be what makes sense
and what is healthy now.
Like if you look at studies on dairy,
almost all studies show people who take
in dairy are healthier,
better bone density,
more lean body mass,
lower body fat.
But it isn't.
Are there a lot of people that think
that dairy is bad for you?
Yeah.
Here it causes inflammation.
Megan's but early,
uh,
some,
some like clean eaters to think that
dairy somehow causes the,
the research data.
Yeah.
In dairy,
uh,
various proteins that a alpha locked
albumin or that can basically initiate
a,
an immune response in the body.
So I know when I'm okay with dairy fat,
I can get like 100 grams a day of dairy
fat.
But if I'm,
if I drink a whey protein shake,
especially at night I wake up all
congested and pure whey concentrate a
way.
Yeah,
way concentrated or just like a,
you know,
a yogurt or,
and,
and I think it's a spectrum,
right?
So it's not like you have it or you
don't.
I think,
you know,
there's a spectrum and bovine protein is
kind of viewed a foreign body.
I mean once it enters the bloodstream it
can.
It's only if it enters the blood stream
because if digestion is working
properly,
you're not going to get any of that in
the bloodstream.
It's all going to be chewed up into some
of the die and try peptides.
Some of it makes,
I mean like insulins have 15,
the amino acid and if you take enough
insulin,
like you can basically go hypoglycemic
if you orally consume it.
That's why you,
I
think it's a,
I think it's 81,
81 I thought.
Oh well it doesn't matter.
Sure.
Yeah,
yeah.
Yeah.
So even something that's a 50 amino
acids can get through this,
this term lactose intolerance.
Do you think that's actually resigning?
That's actually sugar.
Yeah.
So this is an issue with people's
individual dietary system.
Some people have a alpha elect,
albumin sensitive sensitivity where
they,
if they've got some kind of leaky gut.
So normally your,
your,
your injunctions are tight.
Okay.
So your,
your small intestine,
your intestines are like kind of fingers
and they pick up nutrients.
This I'm really generalizing,
but theo cells,
the tight junction is a little little
anchor that holds that gets loose,
dysfunctional with that that can allow
certain nutrients through the wall and
that will initiate a bodies in loon
response.
Holly is a CELIAC and she.
So if she has gluten it you will know it
because she will have a huge
inflammatory response.
But in people who have normal digestion,
that just doesn't happen.
Going back to the Paleo thing,
what I was going to say is even though
I.
I disagree with their relevance,
if you told me,
okay,
you take their general recommendations,
eat limit sugar,
eat more whole foods,
eat higher protein.
I think in general that's pretty good
recommendations for most people.
I just,
as you said,
I'm anti bullshit so I'm not going to
let you make claims about why something
works when that's not why it works.
So when we look at like the differences
in diets,
like I think what I would say generally
to pr people is that here's the great
news as far as fat loss goes and health
markers,
if you want to lose weight,
if you eat,
if you control your calories,
so a calorie deficit,
you eat enough protein because protein
helps spare lean body mass and is
thermogenic so it increases your energy
output and then you can kind of do
whatever you want with carbs and fats
and whatever you prefer and you'll still
lose the same amount of weight and get
about all the health benefits.
But it has to be something that you can
sustain because if you can't sustain it,
you're going to put all that weight back
on.
That's what the research data shows.
So donald loves sustaining it,
meaning for life balanced diet that you
could stick with versus for life,
some sort of a calorie deficit.
That's really only a temporary thing to
lose weight.
Right?
So now obviously you.
You can't eat a deficit forever,
right?
Because then you would starve yourself
to death.
But the body corrects that.
Like you,
as you drop body weight,
your metabolic rate slows down,
you're not in a calorie deficit forever
when we talk about losing weight and
then maintaining it,
right?
So eating in a maintenance,
so eating basically the behaviors you
use in the style of dieting you use,
you have to continue that if you want to
maintain it.
So if you like key to Janet,
like you like key to genic,
you liked you to genic mo and I think
you're a big fan of meat.
If you can sustain that,
you know,
like people out there as,
oh my God,
people will probably tell you you're
going to get cancer and you're going to
do this and you're gonna do that.
Most of those health benefits are just
from not having excess body fat,
excess body fat,
and the metabolic dysregulation of a
metabolic type syndrome.
That's what cause 90 percent of these
problems.
Okay?
Now,
which is why I get crazy when people say
that fat is healthy.
Well,
well here's the problem.
It's like we,
we have like reactionary culture.
So we have been through your set point
is to we have reactionary culture,
so you see this all the time,
so we had,
okay,
you've got to eliminate saturated fat,
you gotta eliminate dietary fat and just
eat grains and limit your proteins and
we got fatter and so the reaction to
that was don't eat any carbs.
Saturated fat isn't bad for you.
In fact,
eat as much saturated fat as you can.
It's great.
Put butter in your coffee like no,
there's good data to show that the
research data that I've seen in my
opinion shows that saturated fat
absolutely was demonized.
It's not as bad as we thought,
but it's if you eat too much of it,
it's not great either,
especially with carbohydrates.
Oh absolutely.
Because now you're increasing your.
Now you're increasing your liver
production of saturated fats as well,
right?
When your body gets into a fat burning
stage,
and then on top of that,
you pile on carbohydrates,
then your body wants to store those
carbohydrates.
As with the Calorie surplus,
you actually technically you store the
fats,
you started because you carbohydrate,
you burn the carbohydrates stored,
right?
So carbohydrate.
If you say,
well,
why does,
if you don't store Kobo,
so I talk about this in my book because
people will go too far to each direction
to say,
well,
you said you don't.
You only use you hardly story.
Any carbohydrate is actual fat.
Why don't we eat zero fat and mostly
carbohydrates?
Well then your body,
your body's not dumb,
your body,
we didn't.
You didn't get here today and get
through evolution in tens of thousand
years of hard,
you know,
living by your body,
being stupid so your body can ramp up
Denovo,
lipogenesis so that you can create fat
from carbohydrate.
If fat gets low in carbohydrate intake,
gets high enough.
Essential fatty acid.
There was a research study or a med
analysis done by Kevin Hall,
who's an Nih researcher,
and they showed that if you equate
calories,
you get a extra benefit from fat
restriction versus carb restriction on
fat loss.
So you get about 26 grams extra fat loss
per day.
Calories equated a protein acquainted if
you restrict fat versus carp.
Now before everybody goes crazy.
That's probably due to a little bit of
inefficiencies in ramping up Denovo
lipogenesis because there's.
It takes energy to move that system,
but 26 grams of fat loss per day to me
is not a physiological like,
I don't care about that.
That's nothing compared to,
okay,
if you like low car better,
don't worry about losing extra 26 grams
of fat if you like glow car better and
you can sustain that,
then do low carb.
One of the things that we seem to be
getting into here is the difference
between losing weight and optimal
performance and then optimal performance
mentally hormonally versus optimal
performance physically in terms of like
athletic,
athletic pursuits.
So here's,
here's something else
type of person,
whether it's,
you know,
you don't want to put a a teenager
that's playing football on a ketogenic
diet necessarily.
Why would that be?
Well,
maybe if they were overweight,
that could be beneficial,
but I think it would decrease his
performance unless he goes through the
Keto adaptation phase,
but there's a lot of the.
At when you're a teenager,
you're I would say your carbohydrate
tolerance is very high.
I want to do.
I want to adjust this.
For My,
my mind was very high.
I could eat huge plates of pasta that I
could not eat now.
I just simply couldn't.
So I think as we age,
I would say our carbohydrate tolerance
decreases with age because our metabolic
machinery is not as hungry for glucose.
I mean we're set up and hormonally our
insulin sensitivity is not as high.
Glycolytic pathways are reduced,
things like that that happens as a
consequence of age,
so it makes sense that as we transition
into age for longevity and for health
span,
maybe not lifespan,
but health span,
a carbohydrate restriction makes sense.
And even in some cases the key to genic
diet makes sense.
You know,
but if you look at the,
okay,
so I have to push backs on that and I'm
not necessarily disagreeing with you.
I kind of am.
But if you look at longevity data,
the actual longevity Davao people who
restrict fat versus carbs live longer.
Like that's what a new study that came
out showed.
But again,
I'm describing it as also a means of of
because people put on weight as they
age,
we're the low carb and with the
ketogenic diet,
that becomes a practical strategy to
create a sustainable calorie deficit for
losing weight.
Sustaining that,
and also if you elevate ketones over
time,
a lot of the new research that's coming
out,
you know,
over the last five years,
ketones is not just a superior source of
energy metabolically,
but it also has epigenetic effects on
the body.
It activate gene pathways that can
confer resistance against oxidative
stress,
that longevity pathways,
anti inflammatory pathway in the context
of a deficit.
No,
not in the context of deficit.
You could feed ketones,
take a ketone supplement,
and it activates a,
just simply elevating Beta
hydroxybutyrate functions as a histone
deacetylase inhibitor and can activate
a,
if you will,
a gene programs that can confer
resistance against many different
things,
uh,
oxidative stress pathways,
and also activate or suppress and
inflammatory pathway that's linked with
many age related chronic diseases and
autoimmune pathways.
It decreases the activation of the NLRP
three inflammasome.
So
what about people living longer?
You're talking about that epidemiology
study that was like a questionnaire or
people what they ate over a long period
of time.
Highly criticized studies and there's a
lot of co founders,
which is why I'm not as hard to say.
It's hard to say that the study shows
that if you eat carbs versus fat that
you,
you live.
I didn't say one was causing effect,
sort of cited in a piece of evidence
because I don't cherry pick because if
we're going to give the argument I want
to give the whole argument.
I was playing devil's advocate.
I don't think that necessarily,
uh,
if you eat a low carb diet,
it's going to cause you to live a
shorter life.
I don't believe that,
but I think it's important to put all
the data out there because what I see a
lot of is people just cherry picking and
I will pose those with those studies
they get.
They become co founders and everybody
will say,
you know,
eat carbs.
You live fat.
Diets are going to kill you.
And then it just gets crazy.
Here's the wire.
Some of the animal work.
I mean,
Lena and I both did animal work.
I think some of the animal work is
almost more reliable because you have an
inbred strain of animal and you have
very tight control if you have
genetically identical,
freely living human,
you know,
he's doing many different things and
there's genetic variability,
uh,
but with animals that it may not always
be predictive.
It's informative,
but not always predictive.
And I think some of the,
the data,
I read some of the human studies and
become a more confused,
but going back to the animal data,
I'm almost more comfortable with some of
these outcomes for animal studies.
So
one thing I want to bring up that I
think is really important is we have,
I think we're all getting to this point
and people out there think that there's
like this perfect diet that's going to
cure everything.
And all of our ails.
The fact,
the uncomfortable truth in the fact of
the matter is that if one diet is an.
I don't know this specifically,
but my guess is if one diet is a better
for cancer,
it might be worse for heart disease.
Or if one diet is better for insulin
resistance,
maybe it's worse for cancer,
it's better for cognitive performance,
it might be worse,
we don't,
we don't know yet.
So that's kind of where is your space at
now?
And this is why I go back to those big
picture things of most of the health
benefits.
Just come from having more muscle.
Lift weights,
lift weights.
If you're,
if you're debating about diets and
you're not lifting weights,
you are fucking missing the point
because that is.
Sorry I curse a so that I do it on
twitter.
You've seen me.
So,
uh,
it's very good at emphasizing your
point.
Yes.
So,
um,
I'm a fan of it.
Awesome.
Fucking awesome.
So,
uh,
somebody criticized me for one day.
I was like,
you know,
what's great about my job?
I can say fuck as much as I want and
nobody's going to fire me.
So that is great.
Um,
but the big picture things,
lift weights,
create more lean body mass,
be active.
That's a huge thing.
Even if you're overweight,
if you're active,
you're,
you're gonna live fine.
But on the whole,
you're going to live longer than the
person who's inactive and then control
your weight,
so if you can even see if you can get to
a normal weight and maintain it or
sorry,
normal body fat and maintain it,
or if you're a high body fat,
if you can get to a lower body fat and
maintain it.
Nice.
That's 90,
95 percent of the battle.
All this other stuff is five percent
that we're worrying about that we're
going back and forth about.
And that's why I don't want to miss the
context because when people like,
uh,
I'll pick on him because he was who
asked for it.
Gary Taubes.
But I'm happy.
I'm happier we got done for this.
But I'm going to just interject.
Hey God,
wait,
wait.
When people like Gary Taubes say things
like carbs or are causing obesity,
just carbs,
you create this problem where if people
don't like eating high fat diet or a low
carb diet and they can't sustain it,
they just feel like they're a big
failure and they just quit.
Because what's the point?
If carbs are causing fat and I can't
stop eating carbs,
what am I going to have a real hard
problem with?
I know what you're saying.
Discipline.
It's important or this nonsense,
but I think my point is that if you give
people flexibility,
it usually improves adherence.
Right?
And you're talking about from your point
of view,
coaching people.
Right?
And what I would like to see is I would
like to see a diet that's protein and
calorie controlled study,
protein calorie controlled.
If anybody knows of one that has done
this,
let me know.
Protein and calorie controlled and then
let people self select higher carb,
higher fat.
What do you prefer?
Let them self select and see how well
they do.
And I bet you would see improvements in
adherence in both groups.
Dom,
you were going to.
Well,
I think a diet strategy that controls
your appetite and does not have your
appetite controlling you.
Uh,
which I think is accomplished with a
ketogenetic diet.
That's also one that's a well
formulated.
One that's controls,
you know,
that has fiber and adequate protein.
A is a strategy that allows you to be
far less fixated on food,
uh,
because you're not as hungry and you can
decrease your meal frequency.
So if there's,
I know there's people out there that are
busy people,
ceos of companies,
uh,
students or whatever,
that simply do not have time to prepare
and eat a meals too when they get
hungry.
So by reducing meal frequency you can
increase your productivity and I think
you're kind of coaching your body to be
a better fat burning.
I think there's definitely benefits.
So when you are on a ketogenic diet,
you are storing more fat but you are
burning more fat.
So think about your adipose tissue as
little bags which have fat coming into
them and fat leaving them and the fat
oxidation pathways or elevated.
And when I eat a ton of fat at night
before I go to bed,
I am like some people carb load.
I'm like fat loading at night and I'm
pulling off those fat stores during the
day through my adolescence.
Uh,
I think about it like that.
So instead of just,
you know,
carbing up at nighttime and I tend to,
I would wake up hungry,
I would probably dump insulin and then
wake up with a hypoglycemic cravings in
the middle of the night if I did that
time restricted eating a,
yeah.
Like today,
like I'm fasting and,
and most days that I want to be as
productive as possible.
I will not have my first meal which will
be typically a ketogenic meal around
4:00
PM.
And what time to eat at night?
Uh,
I will start,
I'll do a small meal like at work and
then I'll eat my big meal at about 7:00,
maybe 7:00
and then snack throughout the night and
maybe eat within,
you know,
I started eating at 4:00
PM and I finished eating and about 10:00
PM.
So you basically start eating at the end
of your day.
Yeah.
So,
and that's very liberating for me.
So.
And I didn't even know this was
possible,
but that's like back 10 years ago,
I didn't know it was possible to have
that amount of control over my appetite
and actually feel as lucid and as
energetic and be able to,
you know,
uh,
get with lane and do deadlifts with him
and actually maintain my,
my performance and my strength in the
gym.
I don't feel like I'm an outlier either.
I think it's possible.
So I think that anecdotes are good
because anecdotes calls us to look at
things.
But I can tell you like,
um,
so for example,
I usually four times a day,
uh,
and I protein right now I'm in a gaining
phase,
so I'm trying to purposely gain weight.
Hopefully some lean body mass.
I'm coming back from an injury.
So trying to regain some weight,
lean body mass.
I'm eating about 400 to 450 grams of
carbohydrate today.
Um,
there were times when I'll go seven,
eight hours,
I won't eat and I don't really get
hungry.
So,
I mean,
there's 16 hours.
Uh,
I don't.
I dunno,
but I don't think I would.
I go some some nights I'll sleep and
I'll wake up and I'll go 12 slash 13
hours,
like I'll go in sometimes and,
and I don't usually get hungry now,
but again,
that's just think that is just a,
well,
if you look at some of the things that
all disagree with or are the idea that
insulin has these big fluctuations and
you become hypoglycemic and that causes
over feeding.
In some people that's the case,
but most people,
if they're eating a,
especially with a higher protein diet,
that doesn't usually happen.
I want
to add that the population,
most people are
not bodybuilders and the population of,
of people that lean mostly communicates
with our on the border of being
metabolically elite and also have a very
high carb tolerance.
If you're a bodybuilder with a large
amount of lean body mass,
you are pretty much metabolically set up
to be a very,
have a high carb tolerance so that the
general population is not like that.
So let's talk about Clark polaroids
because I,
that's one thing that will disagree on.
I don't think that people are more,
uh,
less carb tolerant.
I think that people have sought slower
and faster metabolic rates.
So if you have a faster metabolic rate,
you'll be more tolerant by default
because you could just tolerate more
calories.
I agree with.
But in a bodybuilder that's 220 pounds
on average,
on average.
Yep.
Now,
if you look at somebody who's on a
ketogenic diet,
they're actually by definition of carb
tolerance,
there are carbohydrate intolerant
because if you challenge them with a
Bolus of glucose,
when they click,
they can't clear it.
So,
but that,
that doesn't,
that's just because what they're adapted
to.
Right.
But there are fat adapted.
Yeah.
Great.
So I actually,
uh,
the first experimental biology we ever
went to,
this is why,
you know,
even scientists get this shit so wrong
sometimes because again,
they get so in their echo chamber,
they don't bother to look outside of it
going to the gym when we first met and
went lane stopped and had a huge meal,
which to me,
I was like,
you feel like doing or we're going to
stop and eat pizza for I go squat.
It's a real heavy fatty meal.
Visit the bathroom about five times.
But you know,
I didn't,
I forgot,
I think I did eat,
but it was very abnormal for me to go
eat a meal heavy meal on the way that
Jim,
holly's like you,
she,
she hates training,
fed.
She wants to be fast and she feels
better that way.
But that's the individual differences,
right?
That's the individual differences.
Part of it.
Part of it may be you're just adapted to
that as well and what you're used to.
So maybe a psychological thing,
but some people may just do better that
we're blood is diverted to your
digestive system and processes and
that's less blood for the muscle.
So you're,
you're expending energy to digest
breakdown.
Then similarly is that there has been
pretty debunked.
Really?
Yeah.
But something happened.
I mean it's just a fundamental.
You've got a logical concept that you
are diverting blood resource to,
to a particular job of a scientist is to
question even those theories we hold
most to be true.
Neil degrasse Tyson says,
yeah,
but it,
it's.
So I think a small meal actually it can
be beneficial,
but it's not like you're using Mongo
hydrates during the meal.
You're not using the product.
And how has it been debunked that they
see that performance isn't worse and
that you don't like is the performance
specifically.
There's not a limitation of blood flow
because you've eaten something to the
muscle.
There's not a limitation of blood flow
to the muscle.
Um,
but again,
some people just do better if they're
faster or have small meals.
Again,
it may be a psychological thing,
but I like to feel like I've had a lot
of food and I'm fully fueled for a long
training session,
but some people will feel kind of
training.
No,
like if you're doing something like
squats in a very controlled,
but if you were doing something like it
might be different.
Yeah,
if you were doing Jujitsu,
but I don't know,
you would probably throw up.
Maybe.
I don't know.
I,
I did it very briefly.
Awesome sport.
Like I did it very briefly,
informally.
Also really can't have a big meal and
then go train and get fucked up.
I'd probably have gone to the bathroom
every few minutes.
I can't work on a grant.
I can't.
I'm not supposed to talk about guns,
but mean if I go to the range and it's
supposed to have guns.
My.
Let's talk about guns.
When you talk.
We talked a lot before.
My groups are tighter,
I can better control and if I go in in a
fed state,
I'm just not as focused as that.
My vision,
my vision is not as acute in the right
after a big meal as if I'm fast at 16
hours,
but this is,
this is the hard thing with anecdote
because we can't tease out whether or
not that's.
That is an actual physiological thing or
whether you just feel better and you
think you'll do better so you do better
because the brain is unbelievably
powerful.
There was a study and um,
I may butcher it because I can't
remember it exactly,
but they took people who had legit
allergy problems and they gave them a
sugar pill and they said this will
improve your allergies.
It should not have done anything.
Over half the people reported their
symptoms got better and 30 percent
actually physiologically got better
because their brain was telling them get
better.
Like it's pretty crazy.
So that's part of probably the best diet
for you might be the Diet you can stick
to and just feel real positive about.
Right.
Because you feel like this might be
someone what's going on with a lot of
this low carb stuff that people say they
feel so fantastic because there's some
sort of a placebo effect that's
possible.
I think part of it is too is that's why
animals studies are given me more
confidence when I can look at rats or
mice on a ketogenic diet and see and
objectable,
you know,
objective increase or decrease in a
parameter.
Then I gained confidence.
But here's the thing.
I'm not saying that that's a bad thing.
If you feel good about it,
that's great,
but just don't try to get on twitter and
tell everybody all you're going to gain
fat in a deficit because you're eating
carbs right up.
If you go to a witch doctor and you
really believe it might actually help
you,
yes.
One of the,
one of the number one characteristics of
cancer survivors is that they're
actually.
They have a belief in God.
They believe that they're going to make
it through that.
Now,
some people cause or effect.
Some people will argue religious people
will argue,
well,
they believe in God and so God is
helping them.
The other argument to that is they
believe that they are going to make it
through there and so they have a moral,
a better likelihood of doing it,
so your brain is believe in the
ketogenic diet and believe in God and I
think that's a great thing and that day
they have remarkable.
I believe that you know,
well,
I,
I'm a person of faith,
but I also believe that if you have
faith in the methodology to the patients
that have communicated with me that
actually believed that this approach is
gonna work and then they reached that
actual therapeutic state of ketogenetic
diet have results that kind of defy what
you would expect scientifically.
So I believe it's working
physiologically and also psychologically
there is immuno psycho therapy,
right?
Or immunology.
So our brain can actually control many
different physiological processes
including our immune system and that
that is something that's under
appreciated and under studied and that
really needs to be studied in terms of
eating a large meal before training.
Surely your body has to use up some of
the resources to digest.
You don't think that it's blood flow to
the muscle.
Well,
it's been debunked.
They show that the blood flow to the
muscle is not limiting.
If you've had a meal before you train.
Okay.
Now the thing is,
but some people don't like that.
It's a very individual thing.
It probably,
it may be a psychological thing with me.
I'm not,
I'm not.
I understand that I'm an idiot like
everybody else out there,
right?
So I'm subject to bias and a
psychological influence like anybody
else,
but I just used that to my advantage.
If I feel good about it,
why would I not do it?
Now,
if you train in the morning,
do you do that?
Like heading to the gym first thing in
the morning?
Holly tries to stop me because then I
usually end up going to the bathroom for
like five times,
but um,
I'll eat a little bit less in the
morning if I'm,
if I'm going to go straight in and
train.
Uh,
but one of the things that,
that going back that so many scientists
miss is that context,
like most people miss context,
but scientists,
even ms dot context.
So the first experimental biology study
or first experimental biology symposium
we ever went to,
there was a poster where they fed people
a ketogenic diet or they fed them a high
carb diet and then at the end of six
weeks they challenged them with 100
grams of glucose and looked how long it
took for them to clear that glucose.
The ketogenic diet people would have
been worse than type two diabetics at
clearing glucose.
Okay?
Whereas people eating a high carb diet
cleared it just fine.
Right now if you,
if you just looked at these numbers as
Dr.
Oh my God,
you're diabetic.
No,
that's what they were adapted to and I
challenged the person with the poster I
said,
and he,
for all you kidogenic diet people who
hate me on twitter,
I defend the Akita,
didn't it?
When it is time to be defended,
I said to the girl,
if you had fed a high fat meal to these
people,
you would have seen the same thing in
reverse.
If you would have fed a high fat meals,
people who are out of the ketogenic diet
and then a high carb diet,
you would have seen really elevated
triglycerides,
ldl cholesterol,
Calabar,
Crohn's,
and people who were carpet acted because
it wasn't being cleared because that's
not what you're adapted to.
But people miss that whole context is a
good analogy in his book.
That book where if you have a,
a,
a factory,
military factory that's making planes
and then it has to switch over to making
a ship's right,
so you,
it takes a lot of time to change sort of
all the processes that take place.
Uh,
and the same thing as sort of happening.
I mean,
you're giving your body a different fuel
source.
So it has to ramp up the enzymatic
machinery,
the pathways,
the regulatory pathways and the
transporters even to basically use those
fuels.
Yeah.
And the misunderstanding of that,
or at least an ignorance as one of the
more frustrating things online when I
hear like nonsense people,
these Internet air quote experts talking
about the negative aspects of the key to
genic dye that they tried it and they
felt weak.
Like,
what do you mean you tried it,
you tried it for a day.
Do you try it for three days?
You got it for a month.
Like,
get the fuck Outta here.
You can.
Yeah.
It's important.
Like when,
when you review a study and um,
I think you have a study in your book
actually that shows in the gym.
You basically say the key to genic diet
can hurt your performance in the gym.
So,
and you reference a race walking study
where I think they did the key to genic
diet for like three weeks or something
like that.
So,
uh,
I think we came back around and said
that it's probably fine once you're
adapted to it,
once you're adapted to it,
what's the time period we're talking
about?
For me,
I did not feel myself after it took me
about three to four months.
But then you've got to realize that
there's a learning curve to doing the
Ketogenic Diet.
Right.
So if I go back to my notes,
uh,
I mean my performance in the gym and
just general wellbeing took about three
to four months.
Do you use an app to a child or
anything?
I did a my fitness pal and stuff,
but I just know I'm a creature of habit
so we basically just buy the same food
all the time and I can,
I measure things on scales and stuff
just as a scientist so I can look at
some powder on a scale and do 250
milligrams or minus,
you know,
10,
10 milligram.
So I,
I've measured things out to where I can
look at a plate and basically give you.
The macro is pretty tight and that's,
I don't know if you do that or have you
ever done Quito for long periods of
time?
I've done it before.
Yeah.
And he hasn't been Keto adapted though.
I would argue that the ketones in my
life,
but I just wanted to do it for about
eight weeks.
So you could argue that I didn't do it
long enough,
but my thing is like,
all my blood markers are healthy.
Um,
I didn't see.
So I did Quito at maintenance and I
didn't see really much improvement in
anything.
Everything kind of stayed the same.
Now.
What,
what different energy when,
when was this,
what year was this?
Would've been probably after my
bodybuilding show before I got back into
powerlifting.
So it would have been some in like 2012.
Did you like post about it?
And so I want to go back because I
didn't,
I didn't want to really like get the
wrath of anybody on me at the time
trying it.
Now I'm old and can take a rest.
I just don't care that much anymore.
But um,
I didn't live performance.
Didn't go down that in the first few
weeks it did.
But then it was fine.
I just like the flexibility of having
some carbs.
Yeah.
I liked having that flexibility because
if you it popcorn,
I remember.
Yes I do.
If you know popcorn is great though
because they see as higher protein and
higher fiber.
But you know,
if,
if I was going to commit to it as a
lifestyle,
then that will be fine,
but unless you're willing to,
again,
if that's not something you're willing
to stick to for life,
you have to rethink if you're wanting to
do it or not benefiting going on and off
ketogenic diets.
Correct.
I,
so if you do a key to genic diet and you
want to stay in a state of Ketosis,
the days that I do intermittent fasting
now,
which I didn't do like five years ago,
I don't necessarily do the key.
I do a high higher protein,
low carb,
but my macros or not key to genic
typically not all the time.
Sometimes they are,
but there are different.
Like you could do intermittent fasting
with a car based diet and still get
ketones.
You know,
by the end of your fast.
You could do low carb ketogenic.
I actually think it's a little bit
better to be metabolically flexible.
So I'll throw in.
I tend to eat a lot of vegetables and
then throw in some fruits to have a few
days a week where a,
it may kick me out of Ketosis,
but during the middle of the day when I
need to be at my best,
I pretty much always I'm running low to
moderate ketones during the day and I
can do that with different strategies
now you know,
with my body,
because as much as I kick you out ptosis
though,
I kind of.
That's at nighttime,
a lady and a half of a dark chocolate.
One or two things of dark chocolate and
a which is maybe 15,
20 grams of carbs and maybe a half cup
of blueberries and then a big salad and
some vegetables.
Typically
green vegetables.
When you say kicked you out of Ketosis,
so if you measure your blood,
your ketones dropped below what level?
A point five and I typically don't even
measure at night,
but I wake up in the morning and I might
be about point five and then that goes
up throughout the day.
So the middle part of the day,
I'm typically running one between one to
two,
sometimes three milli moles.
The urine strips are only effective in
the early stages of Ketosis.
Is that correct?
Yak because in the beginning you spill
out a lot of ketones in your urine,
but as you increase ketone transport and
utilization over time,
less of them end up in your urine.
How much time does that,
uh,
depends on the person.
But after about two or three weeks,
you may see less of a color change on
the urine strips,
even if you didn't change your diet.
Is there another effective method other
than the pricking the finger?
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
I think the blood,
you know,
Abbott Labs makes the uh,
precision Xtra.
There's the Quito Mojo,
which I also use.
We use in the lab with a Quito Mojo is a
blood measurement and glucose
measurement device.
That's essentially a because Abbott
cornered the market,
they,
uh,
they basically allow you to check your
ketones for a dollar a strip instead of,
you know,
three or $4 or $5,
but it's still pricking your finger,
pricking your finger.
I don't use the dove,
I actually use a syringe and just take a
running,
start in,
jab my finger now because it doesn't get
calluses like you do on your fingers.
So knowing a,
yeah,
I'm Kinda used to it,
but uh,
the,
the urine strip is actually pretty good
relative marker and the uh,
Siemens a multistage sg,
we'll measure ketones and then nine
other things like that measure kidney
function and,
and you know,
your blood glucose and things like that.
So I recommend that it's twenty five
cents a strip and then there's the
breath,
a key tonics meter.
You blow into it and it measures breath
acetone and uh,
the level is also another breath acetone
measurement system.
Ask about that.
So yeah,
and you know,
breath,
acetone highly correlates the fat
oxidation.
So if your breath,
acetone is high,
you are burning a lot of fat.
So I sit there an issue with people that
are key in the state of Ketosis and they
get pulled over for drunk driving.
A couple of lawyers contacted me.
There's some cases going on right now
and they wanted me to weigh in on that
breathalyzers because of the,
what'd you say?
Acetone breath is.
It uses the same technology,
a breath acetone,
and if you,
I know that if you drink alcohol and do
a breath ketone meter,
you can kind of pin it depending on what
meter you're using.
If you're using a breath for breath,
ketone meter,
if you're using,
if you have a breath,
uh,
alcohol measurement and you're in a
state of Ketosis,
I have not seen that.
Depending on the device that you'll have
a false positive.
If that's your question,
uh,
some devices can,
it depends on the device.
So one thing I'll bring up because you
said,
well,
you work with these kinds of
metabolically elite people.
So one of the problems I say what you're
doing,
where you kind of take yourself up to
the point where you're sort of getting
out of ketosis and then going back in,
that's probably fine,
but most people aren't going to do it
that way.
They're going to be like,
oh,
I had a cheesecake,
or oh,
I couldn't take it anymore.
And I had pizza,
whatever,
that's really bad.
So you see progress,
really,
people who intermittent fast decrease
that window time and overconsume on.
Yeah.
So that,
that's a big problem.
So
actually I wanted to bring up
intermittent fasting too because I think
again,
like if you.
So the studies on intermittent fasting
show that um,
you lose the same amount of calories are
the same,
you lose same amount of weight,
same by the fat,
maybe might be at risk for a little bit
more lean body mass loss just because
you're attributing protein synthesis
left less often.
But uh,
you do have a little bit lower insulin
levels it seems like now whether or not
that's again beneficial based on the
research that we talked about,
unlikely insulin sensitivity,
insulin sensitivity was a little bit
better again.
So there are some techniques you can do,
but people bring up things like a
typology and inflammation.
And again,
I kind of get um,
the soil,
if you,
if you just calorically restrict,
you increase autophagy and you increase,
you decrease inflammation.
Yeah,
you don't get an autophagy is dependent
upon the decrease in certain amino
acids.
Glucose and insulin and you achieve
those biomarkers states at a more
significant level doing intermittent
fasting and then you would and they are
the autophagy regulate.
Can you send me the,
the the reason I am amp amp kinase
leucine,
so if you're eating various meals
throughout the day three times a day,
like you know your blood leucine levels
will be
you gotta keep it in context of 24
hours.
So people,
people do this with fat storage and
oxidation as well.
They say,
well,
if you're,
if you're fasting all this time,
you're burning so much body fat.
Well yeah,
but then by definition if you're eating
less at these times,
you have to eat more at this time.
If you're keeping calories the same and
so during that time post-meal you're
going to store a lot more fat.
You're going to have much higher insulin
now,
maybe not.
Maybe lower overall
metabolism.
You're overshooting and those calories
have to go.
So point being over 24 hours.
You don't see differences in fat loss or
fat gain.
Intermittent fasting versus non.
I would be interested in the
inflammation stuff and the autophagy
stuff because again,
caloric restriction in of itself
increases or decreases inflammation
increases a tough to.
Interestingly enough,
one of the sugar studies they did with
with higher sugar,
with still calorically restricted,
they showed decreases in inflammation.
So inflammation is largely an issue of
caloric restriction or excess.
As you guys think that that's what's
going on with this carnivore diet.
Yeah,
the people,
it's hard now.
I think it's a calorie restriction.
In fact,
it's hard to look at.
If I give you a plate of French fries,
like 200 grams of French fries,
you can get a lot of calories from that.
If I gave you 200 grams of meat,
even a real fatty meat,
it's not nearly the same like you,
you're going to be much more satiated
from the protein.
Like you can only eat so much meat,
you know.
And uh,
again,
like if you,
I don't want to go too far down the
carnivore diet whole,
but the stuff I see with people yet,
do I think you can eat meat and improve
your blood markers?
Absolutely.
Of course you could eat pop tarts and
now,
but,
but the point is,
is like when we get into this kind of it
have only eat meat.
You don't need vegetables,
you know,
this,
I mean again,
it's epidemiology,
but there's some really tight men
analyses that have been done looking at
colorectal cancer and low fiber intake.
And I would not be comfortable
recommending people not eat enough
vegetables and fiber.
I feel uncomfortable eating a steak or a
burger without something like Broccoli
or a salad.
I think you negate
many of the potentially carcinogenic
compounds that are in red meat.
Uh,
and that's a whole nother debate.
But I think eventually,
yeah,
he admired and,
and uh,
polyaromatic hydrocarbons.
Chris Kresser actually brought that up
yesterday talking about meat consumption
with vegetables,
like,
with brought cruciferous vegetables,
Broccolis in Salads.
Like I don't personally would not eat
red meat.
So full disclosure,
I mean I was,
cause I get accused on twitter of being
a car guy and I'm not.
I was live research was funded by the
egg board,
the beef beef,
a national beef something or another.
Sorry guys.
And then the national dairy council,
so you know,
full disclosure,
by the way all you guys out there who
again,
you're just taking my word for it,
but who think that like industry is this
evil thing that comes in and controls
everything.
I met one person in my entire phd from
the funding sources and I met them for
literally 30 seconds.
They were at a uh,
it was an experimental biology and they
said hi,
thanks for.
Thank you for the grant.
Oh Great.
Great.
Great job.
Thank you.
That was it.
Now I'm not saying that there isn't
nefarious things that can happen,
but like when I heard when I like the
show would Nina,
everything was about who funded it and
this and that and,
but that's why they have to disclose
those things on papers.
And also this is why scientists,
science is self regulating because
somebody is going to repeat your study
and if they don't find the same thing
you found you're gonna be in trouble.
So I get criticized for conflict of
interest.
I've seen it on social media and things.
So I should probably say I am not a
medical doctor or even a registered
Dietitian and a phd scientists,
so don't take my word is medical or
nutrition advice.
Uh,
we do.
Our research is funded not only by the
Department of Defense and Office of navy
research,
but also by companies that actually
develop ketone food products and also
exogenous ketone supplements.
And our university owns the rights to
those patents.
I don't have any products myself or
come.
We have a company,
ketone technologies and Quito nutrition
has the information website,
but at this time we have no products but
the university licenses our intellectual
property and products are made out of
that.
And I get patent royalties and I put the
patent royalties back into our research.
So buying various exogenous ketones,
uh,
products that are on the market can come
back and help support the science and
the application of this for him.
I don't,
I,
you know,
I tend not to state that,
but I get called out for not stating
that.
So I think it's important to vouch for
him because he's actually writing a
chapter in my new book.
So we're going to have a chapter about
the ketogenic diet if you're going to do
it,
this is how to do it right.
So the new book,
fat loss forever,
shameless plug,
'em,
and he said,
I just want all the money that I make
from the book to go back into the lab.
So Nice.
Like that's Walter Longo has a similar
with prolon with his line too.
I know his profits.
He,
you know,
the profits that he takes,
he puts back into research is unbiased.
Anybody that says there are is full of
crap.
We all have our biases.
We all have things that we think work
better.
Another.
Sure.
But I think the fundamental,
if you,
if you meet a scientist,
and hopefully I equip myself well in
this and I think dom does as well,
is that one,
you have an open mind but not so open
that your brain falls out and to you
care more about getting the right answer
than being right.
When I went to do my phd,
I was eating eight meals a day.
I was eating 300 grams of protein a day.
I was looking for more reasons to eat
more protein and eat it more frequently
when I left my phd,
four meals a day and a little bit less
protein and less frequently.
And your fractory to the phenomenon.
We're always eating 500 grams of protein
a day.
I was eating like two or three,
two pound London broils and washing it
down with a product metrics with hmb and
it like in between meals back in the mid
[inaudible] 90 [inaudible] and that was
the coolest thing.
It.
Well actually that was the coolest thing
about my research was it changed the way
I actually changed the way I responded,
but I was,
I.
That was my bias coming in,
but I said,
I looked at the research data.
I'm like,
either I believe this or I don't,
and if I believe this I can't justify x,
Y,
Z.
can I get.
Can I go back to the epidemiology
studies in regards to colon and rectal
cancer?
There really haven't been any studies on
people that just eat meat though,
right?
You're talking about people who eat meat
on a regular basis and that usually is
the standard American diet,
a lot of other bullshit and their sugar
bonds and there's tons of the co
founders.
Absolutely right.
I would be fascinated to see some sort
of long term studies on someone who's on
a very strict carnivore diet.
I'm really fascinated by this because
I'm seeing all these people have all
these benefits,
but I am skeptical.
Hippo face every step of the way.
I'm like,
I'm not know.
Again,
if it's allowing them to create a
caloric restriction.
Right,
and somebody says,
you know what?
I've tried every other diet out there.
I've tried to eat high fiber and I've
tried enough vegetables.
I kept,
but I can stick to this and I can create
and I can lose some fat.
Then I want to say,
okay,
well maybe that's the best diet for you.
Well,
I just know so many people that are
benefiting from it,
like a,
you know,
and,
and not just a part of that on the
podcast.
So far I know a lot of other people and
if the members followed by a doctor and
collecting blood work along the way,
I mean those doctors can write case
reports so I'd be glad to assist in a,
in a case report of people are tracking
all their blood markers and doing there,
but most of the people aren't though.
That's what's going on.
Most of these knuckleheads are just
eating meat and saying they feel great
and well there's a war on vegetables.
Like fucking very strange.
Remember that people don't discount
psychology.
People are feeling very positively about
it because it's the flavor of the month.
Yeah.
Like,
and I have no hate towards carnivore.
I don't know who the.
I think Dr Baker Zombie one big guy.
Um,
but you know,
like if I eat hot dogs,
eat grass.
I mean my dogs go out and eat around the
grant,
you know,
to get some cat cats are obligate
carnivores.
Yeah.
So cats interestingly are one thing that
yeah,
they don't.
There is a carb tolerance within.
They don't tolerate them well.
They'll become obese.
But the Vegan cat.
So the,
the.
I think the thing is that I'm not,
I don't believe in any one diet.
I'm not trying to sell anyone dot,
I would like to sell you on a ketogenic
diet.
I really want to see you do it for like
four or five months just to see if
you're experiencing the same benefits as
him.
Pretty obvious that you really haven't
done it like whole hog.
I agree with that.
Totally.
And I think I could probably put
together a meal plan,
Quito,
cookies and things like that.
Where you thinking cookies.
My cookies.
I did.
I technically like,
hang on,
hang on.
See?
I did a ketogenetic diet and it was
fine.
I felt fine about two months.
Didn't stuff suffer that much?
What was your blood markers?
They didn't really change a whole lot
like I had.
I think some,
I would consider them insignificant
changes.
I maintained um,
about your millimoles.
My melanoma.
Do Urine Ketones,
blood ketones or did you look at my
blood?
I didn't.
I didn't measure those.
Oh,
okay.
I just am your instincts.
And what stage were you in from moderate
to high in terms of would have been the
modified ketogenic diet.
So I would have been not super,
but I would have been barely ketosis.
Yeah,
I would have been above point Tom
Wednesday.
So he's eight weeks into it and that's
about the point I was kinda feeling
crummy and stuff.
But.
So,
uh,
so I actually ended up three,
well not crummy,
but I cognitively,
it was kicking in.
Yeah.
But I was a political flag and the gym
and then it started to fill out and then
it's a learning curve too.
Right.
Let's see.
My thing was,
if I can get the same,
if I can get the same benefits just by
restricting my calories and keeping
higher protein,
same fence in terms of cognitive
function,
in terms of.
Okay,
well that's science.
I would say.
I mean we study,
you could look at pub med,
everything from polycystic ovary
syndrome to acne,
you know,
type two diabetes,
type one diabetes.
Now that's a little bit controversial,
a genetic metabolic Migraines,
you know,
a whole host of neurological disorders
simply because Beta hydroxybutyrate is,
I believe sort of from there is an
objective truth that it's a superior
metabolic fuel and if,
how do you define nearly molar levels in
your blood,
that's a significant amount of energy in
your blood that your tissues can use.
How are you defining severe metabolic
fuel?
The objective of the Delta g of ATP
hydrolysis in the heart is enhanced.
So essentially you're making more ATP
for a given amount of oxygen,
just protecting your metabolic rate
could be slower.
Uh,
maybe you are
efficient.
Yeah,
so you're more metabolically efficient
potentially,
but I don't think in the context of fat
loss,
but it's also enhancing insulin
sensitivity and simply feeding ketones.
A independent of carbohydrate
restriction increases fat oxidation in
the muscle.
Those had been published.
There's bits,
there's been studies to look at like a
ketogenetic diet versus a knowledge
eugenic higher carb diet,
and they show that basically by going
kidogenic you reduce overall insulin
area under the curve by 20 percent.
That was the number they got.
Now,
if I was type one diabetic,
I would 100 percent do the kidogenic
diet.
One hundred percent.
Absolutely.
Okay.
That this is not controversial.
This is not medical,
this is not medical advice.
And me personally,
I actually,
when I used to give talks,
I would say for these things,
but if you're a type one diabetic,
you want to avoid the ketogenic diet as
much as possible because there's
diabetic,
something called Diabetic Ketoacidosis,
but that's like my student Andrew Cute
neck at USF as if you've also got a lot
of insulin.
He has a blog on Keto nutrition.org.
Go to it and it's a very detailed
description about carbohydrate
restriction and managing your blood
glucose and it goes into really into the
weeds if you want to reset it.
So can I stop you there though?
Could you elaborate on that?
So you used to say that if you are type
one diabetic,
you wouldn't.
I did because it was very controversial
territory.
Describe what a diabetic ketoacidosis.
Yeah.
So if you're type one diabetic you make
little or no insulin at all.
Right.
And,
uh,
I guess maybe just going back to a
normal person,
when they fast or they do the kidogenic
diet,
it increases fat oxidation in the liver
and that fat oxidation actually
accumulates Acetol Coa Aa and that
creates ketones,
acetoacetate and Beta hydroxybutyrate,
and it curves in the context of insulin
suppression.
But you're still abnormal insulin,
but it's very low,
right?
Uh,
and then when your ketones get elevated,
you spill some out in the urine and
that's how you eliminate them.
Your muscles,
your brain burns them.
And if they get really high,
you have a,
an increase in.
It's a small increase in insulin release
when your ketones get real high and that
insulin ramps down fat oxidation in the
liver and decreases ketone production.
So,
and there's other things too,
but I don't want to get too much into
the weeds,
but you're a very,
a normal person is finely tuned to
create,
to maintain physiological ketones within
a certain range with nutritional
ketosis,
with diabetic,
a type one diabetes that's completely
thrown out the window.
So without insulin being there,
uh,
the absence of insulin essentially
creates runaway ketogenesis.
And your ketones become very,
very high in the context of very high
glucose.
Exactly.
So you have high glucose and high
ketones.
It creates a metabolic,
a disruption.
It creates an acidotic state and
electrolyte imbalances and coma and
death,
which is not going to happen in people
who are healthy,
who are just doing a ketogenic diet.
Right?
But,
but is the type one diabetes,
if you,
for example,
my student,
uh,
using his own example because I think
maybe he was using 20 or 30,
I use of insulin a day,
right?
And then starts carbohydrate restriction
and even a modified ketogenic diet and
can reduce that insulin requirement to
four,
five,
six.
I use a day.
So literally knocking it down to 20
percent of what he would have changed in
your perception when you did not
recommend it a beat.
Well,
there's a Harvard study that basically
looked at a group called type one grit
on facebook.
There was a group called type one grit
and it's got thousands of people who use
a low carbohydrate approach,
not necessarily a ketogenic diet
approach.
Some are,
uh,
but it's very carbohydrate restricted in
terms of what a doctor,
an endocrinologist would prescribe for a
type one diabetic.
It would almost make it look like
suicide to some people and low
carbohydrate dramatically decreases your
insulin requirements.
And if you look at your continuous blood
glucose recordings over the course of a
week,
those numbers are much,
much tighter and that's going to pay
huge dividends in the long run when it
comes to a longevity and health span.
And you know the potential for going
blind or decreasing your kidney
function,
you know,
buy these huge post prandial spikes.
Essentially.
If you're type one day,
you're always chasing your glucose with
insulin injections,
right?
Or an insulin pump.
If you're carbohydrate restricted,
you're basically not it.
It's very liberating because you're not.
Your dependence on insulin is far,
far less,
you know,
some controversially,
some people have gotten completely off
of insulin.
I would not recommend that,
but some people are actually doing that.
So the,
the,
I think,
highly not recommended.
I hear this from critics,
critics of the kidogenic diet,
and this is a BS criticism.
The again,
here's me defending the ketogenic diet
is well,
you'll,
you'll be,
you'll become a people who are healthy,
you'll have diabetic ketoacidosis.
That is not going to happen because by
definition,
if your ketones are high and your health
and you're relatively healthy,
not type one diabetic,
your blood glucose is low.
It's when both are elevated that it's
dangerous.
Okay,
and if you're a type one diabetic,
like Andrew who are just using a little
bit of insulin to get that baseline,
so get your glucose levels down to a
baseline level and then you're using a
carb restricted diet that creates
ketones while your blood glucose.
Is that a normal basal level that again,
not a Dr Medical Advice,
that should not be dangerous
right now over the years because he's a
power lifter and he's a super big dude.
He's like 250 pounds.
Like when he goes to the gym,
he has learned that he can pulse a
little bit of insulin and maybe ramp up
is protein or maybe even take it a
little bit of carbohydrates,
but you know,
the next day he's still doing low carb
throughout the day.
But he's learned to leverage,
you know,
as a type one diabetic,
you,
uh,
you have that advantage,
right?
Because you can manipulate for body
composition alterations or things like
that.
So he,
uh,
he has learned to adjust his protein to
maximize his sort of gains and
performance in the gym.
And uh,
but nonetheless he goes from,
he went from a strategy,
he transitioned to a strategy that would
be a,
we'd look to be almost suicidal from the
perspective of an endocrinologist,
doctor managing type one to do that
level of carbohydrate restriction would
be a.
and now we actually have hard science to
show that that can not only can be done,
that gets that dramatically decreases
the variability of your blood glucose
fluctuations throughout the day from a
weekly perspective and your requirements
for insulin.
Whenever you could use less insulin to
manage your blood glucose,
that's a good thing.
I would say it's very hard for a doctor
to argue against any type.
Would I be using less insulin and
keeping tighter numbers?
There's no way to argue against that.
So if you can follow the Diet so that it
gets back to adherence again.
Right?
Right.
Again,
so it's one of those things,
like you said,
I'd like to see you try it and do it
whatnot.
And you know what?
I would probably be fine,
but I enjoy having a variety of foods
and I enjoy having a variety of fuels as
well.
No,
I'm sure you do,
but I'd still like to see you try it.
Like those two are mutually exclusive.
You're right.
But I liked having a scientist
chapter in his book that's coming out
that we worked,
you know,
tea together and uh,
just took some of the concepts that I've
don't you find here your preferences
change as well,
like in terms of your hunger pangs,
you're not,
you don't crave sugary foods,
carbohydrates,
but you do.
You like them?
Yeah.
Look at you like I'm getting hungry
thinking about it.
Oh my God.
Give me the sugar.
Whereas the pizza,
uh,
no I don't.
When did you have for breakfast this
morning?
What did I have for breakfast spot?
I had a steak and eggs.
There you go.
And the toast.
Toast.
Oh,
you son of a bitch.
Stabbed.
Stab him in.
The face is wrong with you.
Why don't you know,
Spike.
Big serving of nothing.
So lots of energy.
Again,
it's,
it's individual.
And I want to point out that if somebody
likes a kid and I've had people do
ketogenic diet,
I've had people you know,
get ready for shows and the key to take
time that why did you put them on
occasion because that's what they liked.
They were,
they were,
they had that preference for that.
And it got to a point where for some
people their calories get so low if they
have slow metabolic rates,
that the level of fat restriction it
would take them to is probably not great
for hormone levels.
So I tended to pull a little bit more
carb relative to fat and so we didn't
start out targeted them as key to Jenny,
but by the end they were um,
so,
you know,
so you had to resort to something that
actually works.
Oh,
stop it,
stop it.
Stop
Basal metabolic because metabolic
declines.
You get to a point that you get to a
point,
especially to get that lean.
I mean I'm somebody who's a,
like again,
more average muscle mass and pretty fast
metabolism.
Usually I had to get down to like under
2000 calories a day to get,
to get ready for a show.
So for me I was,
I had my carbohydrates for briefly under
100 grams of carbs per day in that show
prep December.
But I was sober.
I was sticking your fingers and
measuring your glucose in the bathroom.
I forget where my theory is that when
you do that and you carb restrict and
you will,
you calorie restrict rather and get
down,
he wants that shit's over.
You just want to reward yourself as
often as possible.
So when someone comes along with
something like a key to genic diet and
go,
no bread,
no pop,
fuck you,
you just,
you just don't want to do it.
You get,
but you get the same.
Uh,
the adherence and the relapse is the
same whether it's key to genic or
another diet relapse,
like regaining weight,
again,
like Pasta and bread because there's no,
no foods actually create.
They've sent,
they have great stuff there.
Waffles are excellent.
They have like a hamburger buns now.
Anything I really like,
I've made sandwiches with their stuff.
Um,
what knocks me out more than anything of
Ketosis is just too much meat.
Yeah.
Genesis,
that's the one that gets me.
Again,
I,
I kind of go back to that.
The data is very mixed.
Again,
if we look at the overall data set,
very mixed and all diets have terrible
adherence,
right?
But a lot of that.
And that's discipline.
Yeah.
But we also,
now we've got some crazy.
I don't want to talk about people aren't
disciplined really,
really.
I really have a giant hard problem,
but how does it know so many disciplined
people?
And I just,
I feel their momentum and vibration and
I'm like,
I just want to concentrate on what
they're doing because all these people
that can't do it,
I feel like that's contagious.
You started thinking about people that
can adhere to diets and fall off.
I get it for you because it's something
that you do professionally.
But I'm gonna.
I'm gonna make it so for you,
the ketogenic diet clicks or,
or eating more meat clicks that that's
something that you really enjoy.
You like the state you lost.
Dude,
I love Pasta.
It makes discipline easier because the
data doesn't support that.
It makes discipline easier in terms of
your adherence or in terms of your
longterm adherence?
Both.
So but,
but hang on,
hang on.
For some people,
for some people this works better
because they feel better.
They have better adherence for other
people.
If you say now you've got some people,
if you say,
hey,
you can have a cookie.
It would,
it would screw them because they would,
they would just go crazy.
But for other people,
if you allow them more flexibility
there,
adherence improves.
What I'm saying is we need to give
people all the options on the table,
not demonize any one
diet and say,
hey,
maybe you try to figure out what works
for lack of sounding Bro,
what works for you and what you can
sustain.
Go from there,
but see this is totally in agreement.
I am as well,
but you keep saying,
Ken sustained.
You definitely can sustain more than you
do that.
The real problem is a giant percentage
of the people are weak.
Oh,
I would agree with that.
I guess in the 30,
40 percent people just quit,
give up,
don't do what they're supposed to do,
don't do as many reps as it's supposed
to do.
Don't work out and take days off just
because they're lazy and those are the
people that get off the Diet.
It's a discipline issue more than
anything.
The that is really big.
So I think various foods that are
emerging on the market right now at base
systems,
Virta health actually has a great app
based system that actually coaches you
through that and I think that's very
helpful.
So I think new technologies,
foods and we'll make it will increase
adherence.
Also,
when you have a person who knows and
understands all the health benefits
associated with nutritional ketosis or
just a low carb,
I think that can be a motivating factor
to make them stick to the Diet,
but for a guy like you who's rational
and discipline,
but people their self destructive and
weak,
they're going to need a burger and fries
and need to share their choice.
What's the point of the whole
conversation than the well,
the part of their conversations to avoid
those motherfuckers because they're
going to drag you down to their mediocre
level.
I think you need to sympathize with them
a little bit because I think the market,
and I think this is a fruitful area for
entrepreneurs to create technologies and
foods that can actually enhance
adherence to stop eating strategies.
We know about that too,
so it's a combination.
How much of it is what you're willing to
accept from yourself.
If you're.
If you are willing to accept this
seesaw,
obesity thing that so many people get on
on and off this Yoyo effect.
If you're willing to accept that,
that's fine,
but I just feel like it's a mental
state.
I really do.
I see.
Once you achieve a certain amount of
success,
people start sabotaging themselves.
They start,
they start dwelling on the fact that
they're doing well,
but how long can they sustain this?
I starts being a big fat mind fuck,
and that's when you say like,
what's sustainable?
What's this data?
A lot more than you're willing to do
what sustainable is?
Stove yell a bit.
The person out there that's listening
knows,
but you know what I mean?
It's like there's a thing like we're
giving people these fucking escape
clauses.
We're giving them these,
these,
these parachutes they can pull.
Don't pull the parachute motherfucker.
Just have a cheat day.
That's fine,
but don't get off your diet.
Have a cheat meal,
you know,
fucking giant Sunday.
Throw some syrup on that bitch.
Get that whip cream going.
Do it once,
but don't live your life like that.
That's nonsense and I think that for.
Yeah,
I wouldn't disagree with anything you
said.
People need to hear.
Not this like this.
Like,
well,
you
can't sustain it.
The Quito giant Sam Houston state to
state their control.
If you do sustainable,
if you found for three days,
that will give you a lot of confidence
that you have control over food fasting
for three days.
No Diet is sustainable.
It's not sustainable over if you look
for the general population and you get a
bunch of weak bitches and you get them
together,
how many of them are going to keep it
together?
How many of them are going to run
everyday?
How many of you going to work out every
day?
Very,
very,
very few.
You're dealing with outliers in
particular.
Just by virtue of what you do,
how many people are willing to put the
work in to achieve this?
That not how many,
how many people are gonna achieve this
physique?
Very,
very few.
Right?
So we're talking about outliers.
We're talking about how.
That's what I like.
I like outliers.
I don't like people that are good to
hear that that's dangerous,
so like that shit is worse than carbs.
That's why we talk a lot in the book
about behaviors because if you change
your behavior,
that's what we,
I think there's not enough research
focused on is let's look at the people
who actually achieve weight loss and if
you look at people who achieve it and
keep it off,
they do it through many different
methods,
whether it's low carb,
low fat,
whatever it is,
but let's look at the behaviors that
they make and those behaviors can tell
us a lot about people.
One thing we know is they practice.
They've made themselves very often they
so they're accountable.
They practice some form of cognitive
restraint,
whether it's weighing food,
recording macros,
ketogenic fat restriction,
whatever it is,
and also they exercise regularly and
one,
there's physiological benefits to that
exercise lowers the body fat set point
that your body will defend.
So it actually has a physiological
benefit,
but also just mentally like you said.
I mean I never.
If you took me back 30 years ago and you
told me,
hey,
les,
or when I was 10 years old and you said,
hey,
when I was bullied and picked on,
had no self esteem,
you're gonna fucking squat,
668 pounds one day on your back at 201
pounds and set a.
it's been broken since then,
but a world record,
I would have been like,
there's no fucking way.
There's no way,
but when you have disciplined like you
said and you that doesn't,
just people say you should have more
confidence.
That's a fucking horseshit advice.
Confidence is built through.
You set a goal and you achieve.
You set a goal and achieve it and you
don't start out to say,
I'm going to set a world record and
that's your first goal.
You.
I like,
what will Smith say?
Say you lay a brick as perfectly as you
can.
Lay it.
You do it again and you do it again and
you do it again and you talked to
anybody who's successful in anything.
They didn't start out saying,
I'm going to do this earth shattering
thing right?
They started out and built that
confidence over years and years of
achieving small goals,
which then led them to their big goal.
Now we're onto something because I think
that the mental state in which you
approach anything,
a workout routine,
a lifestyle,
the way you decide to live your life,
that is,
and here's one of the things that people
are cynical about.
That's probably one of the best sources
of fuel,
is inspiration from other motivated
people.
Go to David Goggins instagram page
everyday.
Watch that fucking savage.
Watch what he does and yeah,
he's awesome,
but go to people like him.
Cameron Hanes,
go to go to go to the rock like these
fucking people.
Just do it.
There's no escape.
There's no acute sustain that.
That's not.
I don't want to hear that shit.
That's nonsense.
Failing is good.
It's okay.
If you fail,
then you're not going to get back on the
horse.
You're not pushing yourself hard enough.
When I say sustainability,
I mean if,
if it's,
if it's because everybody has stuff that
they find,
again,
you find a carb restricted diet to be
easier to stick to three feels better
for it,
better for you,
and that's fine,
but if,
but if somebody is over here and says,
you know what,
I'm eating a low fat diet.
I feel great.
My blood markers are good.
I have plenty of energy.
What's wrong with that?
Nothing's wrong with that.
There's well Libertarian,
oh,
unquestionably exists,
right?
There's A.
There's a giant difference between all
of this.
Some people eat peanuts and they die,
right?
We all know that.
There's just.
The body's just very,
very different.
They're very exactly their caloric
requirements,
the nutritional requirements,
it.
That's what's hard about this,
right?
Is Finding this one thing that is best
for you.
Yes.
And objectively and you know,
and being really analyzing your,
your actual physical performance,
which very,
very few people do.
They kind of say,
well,
I feel pretty good,
but by what marker,
right?
Are you,
what's your personal best?
What are you trying to accomplish?
Are you monitoring your heart rate?
Are you monitoring your workout?
Put like what are you doing to show that
this diet is optimal for you?
Yeah.
Well,
and part of that is like a,
you know,
it's hard to get a lot of money that's
going to be spent to get that data for
an individual.
So part of it is going to have to be
what do you feel good on and what do you
feel like is again,
most sustainable for you because no
matter what that people want to diet,
what people really want is they want,
I don't want to have to track and I
don't wanna have to sacrifice anything
and I want to get to my goal.
Well,
tough shit.
That's not going to happen.
You have to pick what you're going to
sacrifice,
right?
So if you say,
I hate tracking calories so I'm just not
going to eat carbs because I,
I can regulate my body weight that way.
Fuck yeah,
do that.
I had a post on twitter that was one of
my most popular twitter posts.
I said,
you know,
health improvements are largely driven
by caloric restriction and weight loss,
but if,
if you like Vegan,
if you like Quito Carnivore,
if you and I just listed a bunch of
different diets and they help you create
a restriction and it keeps you at a
healthy weight,
then fuck yeah.
Hell yeah.
Like if somebody says,
I like eating a Vegan Diet,
I'm not interested in losing weight,
but Ketogenic,
intermittent fasting is very,
very easy for me.
I loved the food and I feel better and
uh,
I think all my biomarkers are improving
when,
when you don't need any other reasoning
for why you should do it with him.
It works.
Now.
Can I ask you this?
When you say diets aren't sustainable,
the data doesn't show that what you're
talking about,
calorie restricted diets that overall
weight loss diets.
Are you talking about dietary choices in
terms of like key to genic direct
question.
So it's that if you lose weight,
we cannot keep it off.
That is,
that is the big problem is that most
people are able to lose weight and they
cannot keep it off because one,
the self defense system that we talked
about is really weight too quickly.
Their body gets into this state where
it's always trying to regain that weight
back.
Part of it,
part of it,
yeah,
like losing it more quickly.
There's debate about this,
but I would say that it's you have to
create a more extreme deficit to do that
and so you are activating your body self
defense system more intensely.
If I had to say it that way,
so the rebound is usually bigger as
well,
so it's.
It's trying to find a way of cake.
Can we get this weight off and then
let's really emphasize to people that
the diet after the Diet,
nobody talks about this except for us in
the book.
Nobody talks about this like co writer
for the book,
Peter Baker and I,
we spent were spent chapters talking
about when you go and transition into,
okay,
we've lost the weight we want to lose
were healthier.
You have to have the same amount of
discipline and intensity to then
maintain that loss because if you let
up,
if you let your foot off the gas,
now you don't necessarily have to be at
the same caloric restriction level,
but if you just let yourself go on a
vacation,
I'm going to eat.
I'm gonna,
eat what I want,
boom,
gained 10 pounds and everybody knows
people like this,
who they go and they do this and you've
just,
you've literally just undid months of
hard work in one week would say if you
could maintain that for a set amount of
time,
say six months.
So I think that if someone can maintain
that weight loss for six months,
that's like sort of like the tipping
point where they can go on.
Got My wheel house right here,
go up.
So.
So that's a great point.
So Leptin as you,
I'm sure you've heard of people talking
about Leptin,
so when you lose fat,
Leptin secretion goes down because fat
cells secrete it and it's Kinda like
your body's thermostat and body fat.
Everybody has like a set point their
body likes to be.
Yet,
so if you lose body fat used to create
less Leptin,
hunger goes up,
metabolic rate goes down,
Krellan tries to yes and girl is in
opposition to Leptin,
so you,
you.
This is your body like a thermostat,
so if on a thermostat,
if you said it's 75 goes to low,
kick the heat on bumper,
back up,
goes to high,
kick the cooling and go back down,
left and acts that way with your
metabolic rate and your hunger.
When you get down to a low body fat,
Leptin is low,
your body,
you have a drive to regain that weight.
You're your hungers higher,
your boss,
your,
your metabolic rate is lower.
Leptin still stays low even
years after a diet and people who have
kept the weight off so you would think
there'd still be a biological drive to
regain the weight.
That said,
and I'm going to go out on a limb here,
so any of my scientists who are
listening on this,
feel free to call me out on the carpet
if you think I'm wrong,
but just like obese people,
obese people actually have high levels
of Leptin.
They have high levels of Leptin,
but they become leptin resistant up to
an insensitive,
right.
If you stay at a re,
there is evidence that if you stay at a
reduced body weight for one or two
years,
that that can become your new set point
that your body defense.
I think what can happen is even if your
Leptin doesn't go out or two years,
not six months,
yeah,
it's a little bit longer,
a little bit longer,
but it's a good stock aneurysm.
What's happening?
Well,
I think it's probably multifaceted
because nothing,
your body is so redundant.
Usually nothing is ever one thing.
Typically your set point,
I think one of the things that happens
is probably your body becomes more
sensitive to the Leptin you have because
you're leaner.
Now I want to talk about performance
because this is a big thing with
athletes and particularly in my field
with fighters.
Many of them were reluctant to try
ketogenic diet initially because of the.
The first few weeks are pretty rough and
it,
it really enhanced,
inhibits training and you get that Keto
flu feeling and I've experienced that
too,
but overall is the key to genic diet a
good strategy for someone that's
involved in some sort of a brutal
athletic pursuit like football or
wrestling.
It can be absolutely,
and it will be dependent upon being keto
adapted over time and actually training
in a state of Ketosis.
So you forced those adaptations over
time.
We know that the ketogenic diet is
glycogen sparing overtime.
Glycolytic pathways will be decreased
over time,
so that may impair a anaerobic power
output initially,
but I think that most people,
some people,
I think a good amount of people could
adapt back to,
especially if they're taking things like
creatine monohydrate and taking various
supplements that can kind of fill that
gap,
uh,
to meet the glycolytic anaerobic energy
demands.
You know,
that tighter.
Yeah.
Zack bitter,
who holds the American record for the
fastest 24 hour run or 24 the fastest
100 mile run.
He did it in an 11 hours and 40 minutes.
Insane.
He ran 100 miles.
It's fucking just nonsense.
Now she can correspond with him on
twitter one time.
Not,
not by the way.
Very,
very smart.
Jeff Bolek I think,
uh,
brought him to my attention and actually
we're looking at some of the muscle
biopsies from various athletes that are
doing similar things.
Yeah,
he is on a ketogenic diet essentially,
but when he does these long races,
he takes in a considerable amount of
glucose.
Yup.
Yeah.
He
uses those gels and you know,
take hundreds and hundreds,
probably relatively sparingly compared
to a person that's already like very
carb adapted.
So.
Right.
So you just,
you just want to,
especially a hundred mile race,
you titrate in smaller instead of
drinking 50 or 100 grams of carbs,
20 grams of carbs every hour or two,
maybe more than enough to say if you
need to correct us.
Well,
Zach has a podcast that he also does
with Sean Baker and he basically eats
mostly meat.
I mean,
Zach's diet consists of mostly like rib
eyes,
so he's fully Quito to Andy's using
glucose.
I think glucose and this may aggravate
some of the top.
I think glucose is one of the most
powerful performance enhancing
substances out there really on the
record show that,
especially in the context of that,
where your glycogen levels are being
depleted over time.
Uh,
and even from a training perspective,
very small amounts of glucose are anti
catabolic,
maybe argue anabolic in the context of
certain scenarios.
So Lloyd May,
whether drinks coca cola or small
amounts right after he trains.
Well,
is there any benefit to that?
I mean,
you're going to get glycogen
replenishment.
There's research out of a layman's lab
years ago that showed that actually
sucrose replenishes glycogen,
the muscle faster than pure glucose,
which is interesting probably because
the,
the fruit dose gets taken up by the
liver.
So the glucose you do eat,
the liver doesn't steal,
steal any of it,
and it goes,
uh,
your glucose go into muscle.
But I would say ketones to.
So if the science is very new but
exogenous ketones,
uh,
especially in the,
in the context of aerobic performance
key genics or like a ketone Ester,
a key genics products is great.
Ketone esters,
most of the science behind ketone
esters.
Uh,
but there are,
you know,
valid applications for the ketone salts
that are emerging on the market too,
like eugenics.
Uh,
I think that the science just over the
last couple of years has been
incredible,
um,
emerging on that.
And I think it's something to watch over
time.
It's a new fuel source.
It's like the fourth macronutrient,
right?
We have carbs,
proteins,
fats and alcohol.
Yeah.
Arguably it can be.
So I,
I view ketones as they are a calorie
containing energy source.
So they are a fourth macronutrient.
Now,
let me ask you this.
If you were doing nutritional consultant
for say someone who's a UFC champion and
they said,
you know,
I want to get on the optimal diet for
performance.
You don't think that a ketogenic diet is
the optimal diet for performance,
is that safe to say?
Or you would have to experience for a
long period one,
it's going to be individual.
You certainly wouldn't do it in the
midst of a camp,
right?
If somebody month the,
the,
Oh man,
it's such a new season thing to.
It's such a nuanced question,
but the problem is you don't necessarily
get an off season the in the because if
they call you with a fight,
not look nicely upon if you turn it
down.
So,
um,
I think on the research I've
seen,
I think you're hard pressed to convince
me that a ketogenic diet is worse than a
non ketogenic diet on endurance.
I think that's pretty clear and there
may actually be some benefits depending
on the individual.
Um,
as far as repeated sprints or things
where you need that anaerobic system,
I am not ready to say that acute jake
died.
It's going to be as good.
I think that a non ketogenic diet offers
you now this is where ketone supplements
may be actually the best thing possible
because you could be using glucose so
you're getting that fuel source and
taking a ketone supplement where you're
getting that fuel as well.
Not on a ketogenic diet,
but taking ketone supplements that will.
Again,
I don't know.
I think honestly I want to see more
research so I want to see more reduced
fat.
It's carbohydrates,
maybe amino acids,
Korea 10.
I mean,
you know,
just basically trying to leverage all
the various substrates that your body
can use specially under,
if we're talking about anaerobic
Ketogenic,
something you want to have a suite of
different fuel sources,
you know,
and not rely you like metal bought the
term metabolic flexibility,
which is kind of used use quite often.
Uh,
but I think if you train and get your
body fat and Keto adapted,
that provides benefits for recovery.
It provides benefits if you're getting.
What are the benefits for recovery,
uh,
enhanced,
you know,
lower inflammation,
lower chronic inflammation over time,
you know,
chronic inflammation can contribute to
insulin resistance,
poor Glycan,
a neuro inflammation if you're getting
concussions or even subconcussive events
over time can actually cause a lot of
damage.
And I think the mechanism that decreases
inflammation with the kidogenic diet as
opposed to a non a number of mechanisms,
I mean just simply lowering insulin
spikes in glucose.
But the NLRP three inflammasome,
uh,
is something that we looked at.
There was a study where actually we used
the ketone ester and it's published in
the journal Nature Medicine showing
that,
uh,
in response to Lps,
which is kind of like a,
a inflammatory,
very powerful inflammatory stimulant
that it reduces that and suppresses
inflammatory pathways for a particular
pathway compared to,
uh,
compared to,
you mean
so well with your study,
you're always comparing to things.
So,
so what will you,
what was the control group?
A,
the control group for the inflammation
or it was just compared to know,
like control thing.
So it's just like,
did you give us any CBO?
Okay.
Yeah.
Yep.
Uh,
so in the context of being in a state of
Ketosis,
it reduces an inflammatory pathway.
Think of it as a hub and when that's
activated,
a,
you have a host of inflammatory
cytokines that flow throughout your body
and your brain and causes persistent low
grade a neuro inflammation,
inflammation in the body that can impede
recovery processes over time.
And I think that really contributes to
brain health too.
So I might be getting a little far ahead
of myself because that is its animal
work,
but it's convincing animal work,
looking at a particular pathway that's
pretty well defined before you get to
this is their one zero variation between
a low carb versus ketosis in elevation
of ketone levels in your blood.
Right.
But I mean in terms of a,
is there a benefit to the ketogenic to
being in a state of Ketosis with this
reduction of inflammation versus low
carb a?
I believe there is just by elevating the
metabolite,
a Beta hydroxy butyrate,
but I do think even low carb has some
antiinflammatory effects,
but optimal would be ketosis.
Uh,
I,
like I said,
I don't think it's going to be optimal
for everybody,
but I know there's going to be benefits
to maintaining low to moderate levels of
ketones for neurological health and also
for,
for recovery and maybe performance lane.
You were wincing at the mention of
inflammation
more so that.
So we mentioned recovery from exercise
and inflammation and calories
deficit is a very powerful anti and anti
inflammatory.
So I mean Lane Lane address.
Thank you for the context.
My fellow scientists known Zilla
appreciate that.
So one thing I want to,
because because people get,
it's easy to get into black and white
thinking.
We hear inflammation and we think,
oh,
that,
that's bad,
that's bad.
So there's some studies that tell us
quite a bit about inflammation.
Your body actually has an optimal level
of inflammation,
too.
Little inflammation is actually bad as
well.
So if you first chronic.
I was talking about chronic.
Yes.
This is a lot of thing.
A lot of scientists,
ms dot two is an acute.
We can tell about tor and cancer and
people,
acute versus chronic and how scientists
even messed this stuff up,
but you.
So if you,
if you look at studies of recovery from
exercise and muscle growth,
I'm focusing on this,
but I'll,
I'll bring it back around.
If you give Ibuprofen to healthy people
who have normal levels of inflammation,
uh,
Ibuprofen inhibits muscle growth.
If you give it to elderly people with
high levels of inflammation,
they grow more muscle.
So this means that the body for recovery
has an optimal level of inflammation at
likes to be in.
There is a a,
a kind of a curve here.
It's a cox two inhibitor and Beta
hydroxybutyrate is also a costume,
right,
and so the part of growing muscle and
recovery is actually inflammation.
Macrophages and all these sorts of
things are involved in that process.
Now if it gets run away,
if it's too much,
it's not a good thing,
but if it's too little,
it's also not a good thing.
Andy Galpin did a great job on your show
of talking about a recovery versus
adaptation,
right?
Yeah.
So one of the things he said,
if you do ice baths,
you,
these sorts of things,
your in the short term,
allowing yourself to recover faster,
but you're also limiting how much
adaptation you're going to incur.
And I loved that because it was people
miss this.
They say,
you know,
if you're,
if you're somebody in the off season,
if you're trying to grow,
get more lean body mass or trying to get
better at something,
it's probably good to let your body like
for lack of better term,
have some inflammation and not in the
longterm but in response to that
training session.
But then if you're in a camp,
again,
this is where it's context dependent or
like I'm a power lifter getting ready
for a meet and I'm supposed to be
squatting four times a week.
I've done that before and I'm so sore
that I can't squat my fourth session
than an ice bath or something.
I'm not worried about growing muscle in
that time.
I'm worried about getting recovered
enough that I can go do my next training
session because that is a lot more
important for my competition coming up.
Then having that little bit of extra
muscle.
So in camp,
probably a good idea.
Postseason not a good idea.
Yeah,
I mean unless again,
it's all contextual dependent,
right?
Like if you start getting so sore that
you can only train like twice a week,
then maybe a certain level,
but that points back to that there's an
optimal range of inflammation that your
body probably should be in that's
optimal for health as well.
Now I don't think like doing a ketogenic
diet for somebody,
it's going to take them out of that
necessarily,
but I always want to give context
because people hear these things and
they always think it's a positive.
Like in terms of recovery,
I believe that it can enhance the
adaptive process associated with
recovery.
And I also believe that being in a
ketogenic state will enhance your
readiness,
your resilience and your recovery.
So from a military perspective too,
I believe that,
uh,
and,
and that needs to be validated and
study,
but it's something that,
that we study.
When you,
I'm sorry to interrupt you,
but when you advise us to the military,
do they,
do you put them on a specific meal plan
to,
or do they have,
it's more like,
you know,
how to do that grants whereas is being
studied at a very fundamental,
very controlled level from cells to
animal models to human clinical trials
going on and where the data is being
collected now and some of it is taken
empirically and anecdotally from the
field or just from various,
uh,
exclusive channels.
I guess I would say,
uh,
so that I am coming at it as a biased
and I'm,
I'm kind of speaking ahead of the
science,
but I do think that science already
exist showing that you have a greater
adaptive effect just by virtue of
lowering inflammation over time in
athletes especially.
This probably pertains more to endurance
athletes,
so it really needs to be studied in
resistance trend,
mma fighters and things like that.
So there was a recent study that I can't
remember the researchers,
Dave,
I'll send it to you.
I had a lot of criticisms of it,
but they did show that ketogenic versus
non ketogenic diet and people who were
lifting weights trying to get bigger,
that there was actually slightly less
mass using the ketogenic diet where you
think that would be because of the less
protein?
No,
they equated protein.
I'm pretty sure I want to say they
equate it.
Protein now.
I don't know for sure.
So I don't want to say authoritative
today,
but I believe to stay in Ketosis,
you're going to.
How did they adjust for calories?
I believe they did.
So again,
I could be wrong and so I'll go back and
look and I'll,
I'll send it to you if you want it.
Um,
but it is possible like again,
for every given me there's a Gotcha in
certain things.
Right?
So like these things that activate
different pathways.
Well,
part of what ketones may signal as a
deficit because usually you don't have
them in a surplus,
right?
So,
you know,
we don't know if you can like for
example,
like a tough dog,
right?
Like if we're talking about performance
and muscle,
everybody here is a tough gig and that's
a very,
by the way,
that's such a weird way to pronounce
that because it's auto and phagocytosis
so it shouldn't be out of age.
But anyway,
it's a very rapidly emerging science.
And Naomi Whittell wrote a book about
this and it just,
it's like a New York Times bestseller
and that really covers a science.
So licensed since two or three years.
Yeah.
License almost remodeling and
degradation of proteins,
but very high.
What,
what gets me is like people who are big
on intermittent fasting,
they'll say,
oh,
increases a tough Gig,
but you also,
they're also saying you can grow all
this muscle and it's going to be best
for building muscle,
but that's not true because autophagy
autophagy is part of protein
degradation.
So if you're increasing that system,
by definition that's less muscle.
So you're,
there's always a give me an a Gotcha.
For one benefit,
there might be a drawback.
Now,
depending on your individual situation,
maybe it makes more sense.
Right?
Like having the most muscle mass
possible may not be the best thing for
health.
Now we know that having,
having more muscle mass than normal is
good for health,
but maybe having like absolute peak
muscle mass may not be the best thing
for help,
you know.
So it's like,
that's why I was trying to say earlier
there's never going to be one diet that
just fixes all of our problems.
It depends on the individual and what
they're trying to get out of it.
Just like,
um,
if I went to a,
and again I'm not a have much.
I watched MMA for years.
Loved your commentary.
That's where I learned a lot of stuff
about eminent mma,
but if I went to a Brazilian Jujitsu
instructor and I said,
what's the best technique?
He's got to look at me like I'm an
idiot,
right?
Because he's not going to say,
yeah,
a arm bar every time.
That's the best technique for Jujitsu
and that's when people say what's the
best diet?
It's the same thing,
right?
It's completely contextual.
Dependent,
right?
Depends on you and in the case of
inmate,
depends on your opponent as well.
What your goals are,
your strategies and your tactics.
I think what we were trying to really
emphasize is that individuality
dependent,
but also I really want to emphasize that
this show was calories matter.
You know,
calories matter,
even in even if you're eating low carb,
you can't just eat as much as you want
and Herbie is a very viable option
to induce and sustain a calorie deficit
that can contribute to body composition.
But even like you brought up a floyd
mayweather,
whether earlier,
which I thought was great because you
said he drinks a coke after trading.
Well,
it's hard to argue with his results.
But then again,
sometimes elite athletes can get away
with a lot of really dumb shit because
they're so genetically superior that
they were going to do well no matter
what.
Did Michael Jordan eat a big Mac before
every game?
No,
not true steak and baked potato,
steak and baked potato.
Whereas the big MACs Myth,
myth come from fucking by Mcdonald's
model steak and baked potatoes.
Sounds like my wife can eat two or three
big MACs and a sitting and wash it down
with a full sugar coke and still gain
nothing.
I cringe,
but she.
Some people can do that.
Some people can do this,
sure.
But this.
So it's.
It's.
Did he become this great because he ate
this way or can he eat this way because
he's this great athlete.
I probably the latter,
right?
So we wouldn't recommend like somebody
like if somebody is sitting at home and
they want to become the greatest boxer
ever,
don't go pro ball.
Public drinking coke isn't the first
step.
Right?
But this is what we do with nutrition
because we pick out people that we
follow and we go,
Oh I,
I'm just gonna do that.
And it's so individualized.
The sidelines and marathons,
like they'll hand off coax to people.
I've seen it because people just want it
for fuel and people just wanting it for
fuel tasted it is not a bad idea when
you're doing something that's as
grueling as American.
I don't want to say it's a bad idea.
I don't.
Yeah.
I'm not against it either.
If you're a carpenter now it makes
sense.
Dense,
right?
Yeah.
But you want calorie dense stuff when
you're absolutely a bad thing.
Again,
context is so important because we don't
ever drink a coke.
Well,
if you were starving to death,
I promise you you drink a coke,
you know,
so it's,
it's.
And if you need quick energy,
it's probably not the worst thing that
floyd mayweather could possibly do.
Posts but not optimal.
Yeah.
A lot of people eat those honey waffles,
you know,
like when they're doing hikes and stuff.
But again,
at the end of the day,
if,
if he,
if his car was hydrated and take it,
I don't know what it is,
but if he's eating five,
600 grams of carbohydrate a day isn't
really hurting him to have 40 grams of
sugar from a coke if he's like
maintaining his bodyweight,
performing optimally.
When you think about the kind of
grueling workouts that guy puts his,
maybe that's the only way he can maybe.
I don't know.
Again,
I'm,
I am theorizing.
Maybe that's the only way he can get
enough food in is to eat really energy
dense sources of food to maintain his
bodyweight.
And if you started saying,
well we need you to eat chicken breast
and Broccoli and you know,
this organic rice and all this kind of.
He,
he might start dropping weight like a
stone and his performance go in the
tank.
So this is why context is so important.
And again,
like when we talk about people think,
how many times have you seen two guys in
the octagon and just looked at their
bodies and gun,
this one going to smash this other guy
like just in the primal part of your
brain because he was built like a tank
and then the other guy who looks like
nothing just goes out and completely
obliterate.
It,
happens all the time,
all the time,
all the time.
Right?
So it's completely context dependent.
The biggest thing is to make sure that
you don't run out of fuel during these
things,
right?
Or whatever.
And whatever your sport is.
I mean,
again,
I'm known as a carb guy and I had this
powerlifter one time telling me,
he's like,
don't you think you should carb load the
night before?
And I was like,
dude,
you're doing nine reps like you're
doing.
So you get three attempts on each lift,
squat,
bench press and deadlift.
You're not depleting glycogen Harb
Limited.
He's like,
what?
Really amazed me.
Even like you can fast for a week,
which I did,
and deadly.
And it's not a significant a inhibitor
of your.
Of your performance running would be
hills or something like that or doing
rowing prolonged,
you know,
resistance training,
two or three,
three hours,
then it's probably not optimal to go and
fasted to a strength,
an athletic event,
but you know,
it's,
you have to pick the context,
the individual and honestly people
probably aren't gonna want to hear this
from a scientist,
but we don't know enough about this
stuff yet to really say for each
individual person what's best for them.
And that's why we kinda got to go by
feel.
We know you don't have to go drinking
gatorade throughout your one hour
workout in the gym.
Typically,
you know,
I'm,
I'm drinking ketones,
but it's,
you don't,
it's not going to offer you any
advantage.
It's not.
And I did that for many years actually,
and I think guys still do it now.
Of course when we see it all the time,
I got to make your shake in the gym and
drink a interim work.
One thing that,
one of the things that drove me nuts was
I kinda gotten a little back and forth
with Tim noakes on twitter and he kind
of made it out to seem that,
you know,
people were just missing some of his
research because people in academia or
that peer review is broken.
Who's a tim noakes.
Oh,
sorry.
He's a big proponent.
He's a professor in South Africa,
I want to say,
and very knowledgeable and opinionated,
but very knowledgeable.
He said to me,
he's like,
well,
that's because you've never challenged
convention because I was,
I was and and dog knows.
I have challenged every convention in
the fitness industry that there ever
was,
but it's just,
you know,
when,
when people asked me,
he's vocal about it.
Yeah.
Assertive,
but also open minded.
Yeah.
I'm very open minded.
I just don't like if you can't show me a
hard evidence,
you know,
like there was a great quote from Thomas
Soul that I saw the other day.
It said you could ask these in science
and go a long way in terms of sorting
out bullshit compared to what,
uh,
where's your heart evidence,
you know,
and what is the cost,
right?
So it's,
well,
low carb is better compared to what and
what's the cost on performance or any of
these other things.
And then where's
your heart evidence?
Right?
So this is why,
like I said,
science over time,
yes,
you can have industry influences.
You can have muddled data and some
scientists fake data.
We've,
we've both come across this scientist
who have fake data are frustrating.
Is that,
oh,
it makes me so incensed.
In fact,
I,
I won't say anybody by name,
but I used to be in business with
somebody who I found out that I had no
hard evidence,
but I had a lot of circumstantial
evidence that they were faking data and
it's even happens in cancer research.
It's a huge role even in cancer.
And I took this person out to dinner and
I told them was,
I was like,
we're done.
Like this thing we're doing is done.
And,
and thank goodness I did because it came
out later,
people started replicating trying to
replicate this data and nobody can
replicate this data and and they still
had a pretty big following even now,
but you know,
it's,
it's one of those things,
it makes me so mad because then people
would get so frustrated because they
feel like if they feel like scientists
or just an industry's pocket,
why are they going to believe anything?
Any of us say,
you know,
it's so frustrating and that's why
motivation,
money,
power,
ego.
If a labs,
it's a company's funding you for a
particular supplement and you come out
with consistently with negative data,
what's the incentive for them to keep
funding you?
But if you,
if you're always showing positive
results on supplement studies,
settlements will.
Companies will want to fund you.
Of course.
Now of course,
but you know,
it's so seamlessly,
so danger.
But I also want people to keep in mind
that it's gotta be done in a very
controlled,
blinded fashion.
That's the only way around it.
I keep reminding people like people who
say things like,
we found the cure for cancer and the
government is suppressing it,
and,
and uh,
all the scientists are just in the pie.
You what you're saying is you're saying
that every scientist on the planet who
does cancer research is an immoral,
unethical piece of shit.
That's what you're saying because you're
just telling me they don't have friends
and family who are dealing with cancer
and they're suppressing this research.
Come on now.
You know,
and that's,
that's the other big.
I'm a,
I'm a small government guy and I'm like
I said Libertarian,
but one of the things that makes me
cringe about libertarian sometimes as
these big elaborate conspiracy theories
that come up around science and whatnot,
like you realize like a senator can't
even a text,
a dick pic to is his side chick without
like,
it winded up all over twitter.
You think they constructed these big
elaborate theories.
They can't even tie their shoes in the
morning without spending $10,000.
You know?
So the idea that like all this research
is being suppressed by the government.
I'm not saying it's never happened,
but I think it's pretty darn rare.
Well Gentlemen,
we just did three plus hours.
Thank you.
Felt like six.
I'll just appreciate you giving us.
Thanks for illuminating this stuff,
which is still.
It's so complex.
That's part of the problem and I think
we give you 100 of these shows and we'd
never cover all the topics are all the
issues are all the details and I think
it's so incredibly difficult for people
to find the right diet and program that
works for them.
I'd like to add one thing that the
science is rapidly emerging and the
metabolic health summit,
which is happening in a the end of
January,
beginning of February next year 2019,
we'll be bringing in the leading
scientists that are talking about all
the different topics right now including
your weight loss and that's going to be
in la.
It's actually there's a flyer in your
book there.
If you look inside there giving you a
flyer.
All right,
La,
a January 31st to February third in Long
Beach Metabolic
health summit.com.
It's going to be very comprehensive
group of,
of basic scientists,
clinical scientists,
entrepreneurs and people everyday people
that are just interested in this space.
You going and I will be added.
I'm helping to sort of organize and
promote it,
uh,
but also moderating some of the things
we're going to hit on.
Basically every topic that was discussed
in my last podcast in this podcast,
the leading scientists I'm going to show
up and heckle.
Yeah.
So we,
we definitely went lay in there too and
I think it would be great to have a
panel discussion that addresses this
with a couple more experts and
personalities and in that
it's amazing how much information you
have to absorb.
It's really,
I've done so many diet podcasts and am
still a moron.
That's why you'll,
I always tell people,
you know,
it's hard because if you're not going to
do a degree yourself or do research
yourself,
it's so hard to know who,
like you kind of have to pick people
that you trust.
Right?
And it's so hard to know who to trust
because there was something that,
uh,
Greg knuckles really smart guy said that
I think kind of ties things together
nicely.
He said,
people are really good at knowing when
somebody has more knowledge than them
about a subject.
Like you talked to somebody for a little
bit and you,
you really can get an impression pretty
quickly if they know more or less than
you are about the same.
What they're really bad at doing is
figuring out amongst two people who know
more than them,
who is the more knowledgeable of the
two.
They are very bad at picking that out.
So you kinda got to pick people who you
trust.
Now,
if you're looking for people to trust,
notice the three magic words that me and
him both sit on here today.
At one point,
I don't know it well.
Usually experts,
they don't make broad claims.
They don't use superlatives.
They don't say things like best,
worst,
never always.
They're usually putting context to
everything and they're providing you
with information that helps illuminate
you.
That everything is nuanced.
And that's why like,
I'm sure,
again,
I'll relate it to mma.
If you talk to anybody who's an expert
in any different discipline and you
asked them abroad question,
you're going to get a really broad
answer and if you ask them a specific
question,
give him a lot of contexts,
then they'll give you a specific answer.
But I would you agree with that?
Yes,
definitely.
So I think someone's strong on one
side,
dig kind of deep and look for conflicts
of interest to and kind of.
So I think that's kind of an important
thing.
I try to be transparent as much as
possible on,
on sort of things we're involved in.
So I think that super important without
bias too.
I mean I sell stuff,
I've got a book out,
I've got another book coming out of a
website,
you know,
so it's.
Yeah,
but you're not actually.
Well not advocating any particular
approach,
you're kind of approaching it from what
I'm selling isn't really sexy.
They're complete contest prep guide and
this is available on all those places.
[inaudible] dot com,
[inaudible] dot com.
And your twitter,
bio lane,
instagram,
bio lane.
And Dom yet a kito nutrition.org
and a ketone technologies as our
company.
Uh,
it's an information website.
I don't have any products per se,
at least not yet,
but I put products on there that I
personally use and kind of vetted out
that I think could be helpful.
And just a lot of information like your,
your prior podcast with me is on their
costs in a and Tim Ferriss and Rhonda
Patrick to have right on the front page.
Your twitter and instagram.
Yeah.
Uh,
dominic d'agostino dot Katie.
I think his instagram,
not a huge instagram back,
but a Degas Dino,
d a g O,
s t I two a is my twitter handle.
Uh,
and Dominic D'agostino for facebook too.
So there were three gentlemen,
I think we got a lot accomplished today.
Thank you so much.
Really appreciate,
appreciate,
appreciate it.
Thanks Joe.